موقع «الرجاجيل» حسب الدراسات اللي عملوها والأبحاث
يعود -على ما أعتقد- لـ 4500 سنة قبل الميلاد
هو اسمه حلو، لما تقول «رجاجيل» أنه أيش...
فهي كانت عشان لما الناس تشوفها
تكون مثل ما تقول الرجاجيل المقبلة، ناس جاية
قرية «الفاو» الجميل فيها، لما عثروا عليها
عثرت عليها على ما أعتقد «أرامكو»
فهو يعود للمملكة «كندة»
عرب مننا وفينا، من السعودية نقول
أنا أشبهها في «بومبي»
عندك صحراء «خريص» قبل 20 مليون سنة كانت بحر
إلى اليوم تشوف فيها أسنان القرش المتحجرة
أنا بنفسي رحت الموقع وشفتها
من الاكتشافات الظاهر مؤخرًا هي موضوع كنيسة في «الجبيل» صحيح؟
هذا سقراط من إذاعة ثمانية، وأنا عمر الجريسي
أستضيف قادة التحول وقادة الأعمال وقادة الرأي
ضيفة حلقتنا اليوم هي الأستاذة «حصة بنت مروان السديري»
باحثة ومختصة في الآثار
موضوع الآثار من المواضيع اللي اهتمت فيها الرؤية
فهل عندنا ما يستحق هذا الاهتمام؟
البداية كانت بأن أخذتنا حصة في جولة
على أهم الآثار حول المملكة
السعودية، فيها واحد من أقدم ثلاث مواقع على الإطلاق في قارة آسيا
فيها حضارة من أقدم الحضارات في جزيرة العرب
وتوازي في قِدمها حضارة «سبأ»
تكلمنا على هذه الحضارات
قيمتها، طريقة التعامل معها، طريقة التنقيب عنها
ما هي دلالات كل أثر من هذه الآثار؟
تكلمنا حتى على الآثار الأخرى
مثل واحد من أكبر أنهار في الجزيرة العربية
أيش قصته؟ ومتى كان يجري؟
ليش نشوف آثار لفرس النهر في وسط الصحاري السعودية؟
وعدة مواقع أخرى، حكينا حكاياها، وفهمنا أيش آثارها وأيش دلالاتها؟
وأيش ارتباطها بالسعودية اليوم؟
وختمنا بمجموعة من أسئلتكم الثمينة
مثل، هل فيه جن يحرسون هذه الآثار؟
ليش صارت وفيات لما تم الكشف عن بعض الآثار في الحضارة الفرعونية؟
ومنها نشأت هذه الفكرة، فكرة الجن اللي يحرسون
أيش الخلفية حقتها؟
أيش مراحل التنقيب؟ وكيف يعرفون عمر هذا الأثر
أنه قبل ألف سنة وللا ألفين سنة وللا ثلاثة ألف سنة؟
سولفنا على موضوع أصل العرب، أولًا النقوش العربية
هل صحيح أن أصل العرب في اليمن؟
وللا فيه آثار أخرى قد لا تؤيد ذلك؟
إلى آخر أسئلتكم الثمينة
شكرًا للراعي الرسمي شركة «صفا»
أترككم مع الحوار
حيّاك الله حصّة، شرّفتي ونورتينا
أهلين، شكرًا لاستضافتي في برنامج سقراط
الله يحييك
أنا لو أحد قال لي أنه يهتم أو يعمل أو تخصص في التراث والآثار
بكون مستغرب، بالذات الفترة السابقة
اللي ما كان القطاع جاذب ولا مغري
ولما يكون اللي قاعد يتكلم بنت؛ فبزداد تعجبًا
أيش دخلك في قطاع التراث والآثار؟
والله من أنا صغيرة مع والدتي مرة كنت أهتم
والدي، الله يغفره، كان يقرأ كثير؛ فترك لي مكتبة كبيرة جدًّا فيها كتب
فكنت من فترة لفترة أفتح وأشوف
ما كنت أفهم اللغة، شوي معقدة
حتى جدي كان يحب الفترات
سمّى أبوي «مروان» عشان أبوي يسمي أخوي اللي الآن «عبدالعزيز»
«عبدالملك» عشان «عبدالملك بن مروان»
كان مرة يحب الفترة الأموية
فكان موجود عندنا حب الآثار في العائلة
والحمد لله، أمي تركت لي كتب الوالد، الله يغفر له
فكنت بعد ما تخرّجت؛ صرت أقرأ زيادة
وصراحة الشخص الأساسي اللي دعمني
ومرة كان يدفّني أني أصير أفضل، هي والدتي «إيمان»
ودي أفهم طبيعة الحوار اللي تصير بينك وبينها
في موضوع اختيار تخصص ما له وجود في السعودية
أنا ما كنت أعرف أنه موجود أصلًا، كنت أحسبها هواية لي
لأن لما نسافر دائمًا نروح إلى مواقع أثرية
تعرف أني أحبها، من أنا عمري ثمانية سنين
فدائمًا تقعد تشرح لي عن المواقع، لما نسافر ونروح أماكن أثرية
وعادي تقول لي اسألي، ما تجاوبني كطفلة
فأتذكر في الجامعة، لما جيت أدرس
فكنت أقولها، خلاص أيش بدرس؟ مو مرة كنت أهتم
فقالت لي حصة، ليش ما تدرسين علم آثار؟
قلت، هل هذا موجود؟ قالت إيه، تخصص
وقتها ما كان مفتوح للبنات في السعودية
فحجزت لي رحلة، ورحت للأردن
وشفت الجامعة الأردنية، وقابلت الدكاترة
وعلى طول في نفس الرحلة
أنا كنت على أساس رايحة كم يوم؛ مددت وقدمت أوراقي ورجعت
والحمد لله، منها بدأت رحلتي
كم جلستي في الأردن؟
قعدت من 2009، تخرجت جامعة 2013
بعدين قعدت في الأردن أسوي أبحاث
تطوعت بالمتحف الأردني
وقتها ما كانت فيه فرص للبنات في مجال علم الآثار
وتم رفضي بحكم أني بنت
قدمتي؟ حاولتي؟
إيه، بس ما كان فيه فرصة
لأن كان فقط المتاح وقتها بالمتحف
وكان الشغل بالمتحف هناك مو مثل بالأردن
كنت أشتغل مع القطاع الأثري بالقطع وترتيبها
في نفس مواقع التنقيب، صح؟
كانوا لما تجي القطع من المواقع؛ احنا نعيّنها، ندرسها
وكان شغلي مع المتخصصين أكثر
ففي السعودية كان شوي يختلف
أنا مو تخصصي علم متاحف
علم المتاحف يبغى له شخص متخصص
أن أنت عندك القطع، فيه قطع ما تحتاج نور كثير
فيها كيمياء، وأنا أبعد شيء عن الكيمياء
فبعدها رجعت للأردن، كملت دراسة، أخذت دورات
أخذت دورات في «الفيسفساء» أخذت كذا دورة
وبعدين انتقلت إلى ألمانيا في برلين
واخذتي هناك ماجستير في السياحة؟
إيه، أخذت أول شيء لغة
ليش ما كملتي آثار؟
لا، أخذت لغة أول شيء
بعدين أخذت كمان هناك دورات بالفنون
بعدين أخذت الماجستير في إدارة فعاليات الفندقة والسياحة الدولية
بس عملت رسالتي عن كيف الترويج للسياحة
عن طريق المواقع الأثرية في تجربة تفاعلية
لأن إذا أنت تكون فقط مستمع
حتى لو أنا مهتمة، إذا أحد بيقعد فوق رأسي...
شوف الإنسان الطبيعي، أنت بتقعد ممكن تسمع عشر دقائق
بعدها ما راح تسمع، خلاص بتطفش
فكانت الرسالة حقتي كيف تكون التجربة تفاعلية
حتى للأطفال، للكبار، حتى للأشخاص اللي مو مهتمين
كيف أنت تستهدفهم
فهذه كانت دراستي
دراسة الماجستير
إيه، الرسالة التي عملتها
وأنتِ ما رجعتِ إلى السعودية إلا قريب
إيه
أتوقع السنة هذه أو قبل سنة؟
حبسة كورونا، ما أتوقع أي أحد يحسبها سنين حياته
فبعده سافرت مرة ثانية ورجعت قريب
فيه ناس أول ما أعلننا على الحلقة
قالوا أيش علاقة سقراط في الآثار والتراث، أنتم مهتمين بالرؤية
فأنا أتذكر من الإجابات الملفتة للنظر
واللي عالقة في ذهني في مقابلة الأمير محمد مع «تركي الدخيل»
المقابلة اللي أُعلن فيها عن الرؤية
وتحدث فيها الأمير عن ركائز الرؤية ومحاورها
وكانت وحدة من إجابات الأمير محمد، الله يحفظه، هي
كثير يربط أن تاريخ جزيرة العرب مربوط بـ 1400 سنة والتاريخ الإسلامي
التاريخ الإسلامي بلا شك أهم مرتكز ومنطلق لنا
ولكن عندنا عمق تاريخي ضخم جدًّا
ويتقاطع مع كثير من الحضارات
التاريخ العربي من آلاف السنين
وهو تاريخ الكلمة والقيم والمبادئ
عندنا جزء من حضارات الأوربية داخل السعودية
عندنا حضارات مندثرة عمرها آلاف السنين
يجب أن نستغل هذه الحضارات، ونستعملها بشكل أو بآخر
هذا الكلام في هذيك اللحظة، بالنسبة لي كان غير مفهوم
لأن ما عمرنا، أو على أقل تقدير أنا ومحيطي
ما أذكر أن موضوع التراث والآثار كان جزء من دراستنا
أو جزء من اهتماماتنا، أو جزء من تركيز الإعلام عنها
بالعكس، يمكن كان فيه نوع من نظرة شوية سلبية
بأنها جاهلية أو أصنام، أو أشياء يجب أن لا تضخم
فهذا الموضوع يعتبر فيه صميم الرؤية، ومن أوائل وعودها
فخلينا نبدأ من عندك ونقول
أيش هي الحضارات اللي في السعودية
اللي كان يحكي عنها الأمير محمد في هذه المقابلة
أتذكر أول ما حكى الأمير محمد وأعلن عن 2030
كمية المكالمات اللي جاتني
إن حصة جاء دورك، الحين الأمير محمد قاعد يحكي عن الرؤية
وعن كذا، وعن تخصص علم الآثار
فالنقلة النوعية اللي صارت في مجال علم الآثار في السعودية؛ جدًّا كبيرة
وهذا يؤكد بما أن الأمير بنفسه مهتم، وهذا شيء جدًّا جميل
لما تسمع القيادة نفسها تحكي عنه
بنجي احنا على أيش صار في القطاع
لكن ابتداءً شوّقينا، علّمينا
أيش الكنوز اللي موجودة عندنا وما احنا عارفين عنها؟
شوف الموضوع جدًّا ضخم، نبدأها من أقدم موقع موجود عندنا
اللي هو «الشويحطية» بالجوف
هذا أقدم موقع في الجزيرة العربية
وثالث أقدم موقع في قارة آسيا
فعمره 1.3 مليون سنة
للأسف الموقع ما رُجع نُقّب فيه
كانت آخر دراسة بالتسعينيات الميلادي
هذا  الموقع جدًّا مهم، لأن نفس الأدوات اللي حصلوها
نفسها اللي موجودة في أقدم مواقع في إفريقيا
فهذا معناته دليل أن الإنسان دخل من إفريقيا
على الجزيرة العربية عن طريق السعودية
هل فيه أكثر من هذه المواقع؟
هل هناك أقدم؟ 100%
بس عشان نفهم، الموقع هذا عبارة عن أيش؟
هي فترات العصور الحجرية، تشكّل 95% من حياة الإنسان
لأن قعد الإنسان 3 مليون سنة
ما في كتابة، بس فيه أدوات
فاحنا ما نقدر، وأغلبها تكون نظريات
بس الدليل القاطع اللي يكون عندنا
هي الأدوات الحجرية اللي يتركونها
سواءً كانت فؤوس، رؤوس أسهم وغيرها
تكون أدوات صوانية وحجرية وغيرها من المواد
حسب المواد الخام اللي موجودة بالمنطقة؛ يُصنع منها الأدوات
وكثير تنتشر عندنا بالمملكة
عندك مثلًا بـ«الدوادمي» 200 ألف سنة موقع
فالعصور الحجرية بالمملكة بشكل عام ضخمة
وكل يوم قاعدين نسمع أكثر وأكثر
بعدين هنا نجي لموقع العصور الحجرية
المملكة تشكّل نقلة نوعية
في العصر الحجري الحديث على مستوى عالمي
شلون؟
العصور الحجرية اللي عندنا كان الإنسان متقدم عن غيره، عندما نقارنه
إنسان الجزيرة العربية؟
إيه، في السعودية
فلما نجي نشوف مثلًا موقع «نحت الجمل»
على هذه النظريات، قبل ما كانوا يعتقدون أن إنسان قبل 5600 سنة
كان يقدر ينحت شيء بهذا الحجم
فهو أقدم نحت للشكل الحيواني الطبيعي بالعالم
أنت تحكي من 5600 سنة قبل الميلاد إلى 5200 سنة
وين موقعه هذا؟
بالقرب من «سكاكا» بالجوف
والأجمل بهذا أنهم لقوا الأدوات اللي تم النحت فيها
وصارت دراسة كبيرة والإعلان...
طبعًا هذا شكري يعود لجهود لأمير بدر وزير الثقافة
لأن هو بنفسه كان مهتم بهذا الموضوع
ولما تشوف هذه المواقع قاعدة تطلع عندك
فيه عندك مثلًا حضارة «المقر» استئناس الخيل
ففيه نظريات الآن قاعدة تطلع
أنا أتذكر كنت أحكي مع دكتور ألماني
كنا نحكي على «نحت الجمل»
قال لي تعرفين سوى ضجة مرة كبيرة. قلت ليه؟
قال معناته ممكن استئناس الجمل يكون في المملكة
هذا مو أكيد لكنه وارد
استئناس الجمل وللا الخيل؟
الجمل ممكن الآن كمان
هو يعود أقدم استئناس للجمل في إفريقيا
لكن أنت لما تنحت جمل بهذا الحجم
إلا أن أنت مسيطر على طريقة متى أنت تستأنسه
معناته كان له دور مهم بالمجتمع نفسه
فاحنا في الآثار مو بس ندرس النحت وفقط
المجتمع نفسه، ليش سوى هذا؟
أيش معناه ما كان خيل مثلًا؟ أيش معناه ما كان كذا؟
إلى الآن في البادية عندنا، الجمل جدًّا مهم
فهذا يعكس على المجتمع المحلي
مدى التقدم اللي هم كانوا فيه
أن أنت قدرت تنحت نحت فني بهذا الشكل
معناته فيه عندك جماعات مختصة
حتى الرسوم الصخرية، أنا باعتقادي الشخصي
المملكة ممكن تمتلك نقوش، لو تم توثيقها وحصرها
على رقم واحد بالعالم
لأن مستحيل تروح منطقة ما تلقى نقش أو نحت
والرسوم الصخرية في منطقة نجران
فن أنا في حياتي ما شفتها
الرسوم مثلًا مشهد تلقاهم يلعبون «اللير»
اللي يسمونها القيتار، الآلة الموسيقية وهي من أقدم الآلات
تلقاهم يعزفون الناي
الناي أقدم آلة موسيقية -إلى الآن- تم العثور عليها كأثر في أوربا
أنت لما تشوف هذه المشاهد الموسيقية؛ معناته أن في استقرار
لو أنت كنت في مشكلة حرب وعدم استقرار
ما راح يفضى الشخص
منت فاضي تعزف
بالضبط، منت فاضي تعزف، وتكتب قصائد حب وغيرها
فتلقاها من جميع الفترات النقوش
سواءً كانت «ثمودية» «سبئية» «صفوية»
هذا يعكس لك العمق التاريخي للمملكة
لما أنت عندك نقوش بهذا الكم
معناته الشعب اللي كان موجود مثقف
لما كل أحد يقدر يكتب، غير لما كل أحد يكون أُمّي
إذا انحصرت الكتابة على جماعة معينة؛ ما راح تكون بهذا الشكل
فهذا يعكس لك ثقافة المجتمع من آلاف السنين
فكان الناس تقرأ وتكتب
تحكي من ألف سنة قبل الميلاد
برضه من المواقع المهمة، حضارة «المقر» كذا اسمها صح؟
إيه «المقر»
لو تسولفين لنا عنها
حضارة «المقر» يعود تاريخها لـ 9000 سنة
تم العثور فيها على كثير من الأدوات، وفيها استئناس للخيل
ذكروا أقدم استئناس يعود لهذه الحضارة
أقدم استئناس في؟
للخيل في العالم
في العالم؟
إيه في العالم أقدم استئناس
هذا مثبت؟
مثبت. هذه موجودة، وعملوها على أيام هيئة السياحة والآثار
بس المشكلة أن فيه كثير مواقع مهمة مثل «المقر» و«الشويحطية»
ما رجعوا وتم التنقيب فيها
فإذا إذا أنت لقيت شيء مهم بسيط مثل كذا
تخيل لما توسع البحث؛ أيش ممكن الأشياء اللي تطلع لك
حضارة «المقر» حتى لقوا فيها أدوات الصيد
وين موقعها هي؟
قريبة من «وادي الدواسر»
أنتِ دائمًا متثبتة كل المواقع مربطه من «وادي الدواسر»
شوف هي بين موقعين، بس صراحة المنطقة الثانية نسيت اسمها
بس، إن شاء الله، يسامحوني إذا قلتها هذه المرة
وفي موقع ثاني كمان بـ«وادي الدواسر»
بس هذه موجودة هناك، عبارة عن ايش؟
ليش هي مهمة؟
لأن هنا فيها الجماعة كانت...
لقوا كمان رسوم تصويرية للحيوانات اللي موجودة
أدوات، رسومات الصيد، كانوا يصيدون بالصقور، الكلاب السلوقي
فكان الاستيطان في المنطقة استمر فترة طويلة
فأنت عندك بالعصور الحجرية إذا الاستيطان استمر لفترة طويلة
معناته المنطقة كانت غنية، وتوفر احتياجات للمجتمع المحلي
مثل الموية، الأكل وغيرها
فهذا العصر الحجري بشكل عام بالمملكة
جدًّا مهم والمواقع اللي فيه جدًّا جميلة
كأني قريت أنهم لقوا 2000 قطعة وأداة من أدوات العصر الحجري
هذه كلها بالفعل مستكشفة وموجودة وللا لا؟
إيوة، عاد وين موجودة أو معروضة صراحة ما أعرف
بس أنها موجودة، وكتبوا عنها حتى في «طرق العرب»
المعرض اللي كان يلف حول العالم
فكانوا عارضين جزء من اكتشافات حضارة «المقر»
برضه من المواقع الأثرية المهمة موقع «الرجاجيل» في «سكاكا»
إيه
سولفي لنا عنه
هو اسمه حلو، لما تقول «رجاجيل» أنه أيش...
هي كانت عشان لما الناس تشوفها
تكون مثل ما تقول الرجاجيل المقبلة، ناس جاية
لأنها عواميد
فالعصور الحجرية دائمًا مرتبطة
لأن فيه فترة صار فيه نقلة نوعية للإنسان
صار يزرع، صار فيه استقرار
أول كانت الجماعات متنقلة
فموقع «الرجاجيل» حسب الدراسات اللي عملوها والأبحاث
يعود -على ما أعتقد- لـ 4500 سنة قبل الميلاد
ولاحظ أنه بالجوف، هناك عندك «الشويحطية»
والآن عندك العصر الحجري الحديث، موقعين
اللي هو «نحت الجمل» وموقع «الرجاجيل»
فهذه كلها في منطقة وحدة
المميز فيه أن لما عثروا...
هي اتجاهات العواميد كل وحدة متجهة على جهة
وفيه عليها رموز، فهي متصلة بالفلك
فممكن تعطي دلالات على مواسم الزراعة، مواسم هجرة الحيوانات
أغلب الأشياء والدلالات تكون مرتبطة
لأن عليها تعتمد على حياة الإنسان
متى بيصيد، متى بياكل، متى بيزرع
وهي عبارة عن أيش؟ تشكيل طبيعي وللا من صنع الإنسان؟
لا، من صنع الإنسان، هم اللي حطينها
وهذا اللي يثبت لك. لأنه لو تشكّل طبيعي كان وجدتها في كذا مكان
وموجود عليها نحت، رسم
نسيت صراحة أيش الرمز
وعملت عنه بحث مرة حلو الدكتورة «منيرة المشوّح»
برضه من المواقع المهمة قرية «الفاو»
أيش قصتها؟
قريبة من «وادي الدواسر»
هي من 300 قبل الميلاد إلى 300 ميلادي
تعود لمملكة «كندة»
قرية «الفاو» ازدهرت كثيرًا على الطرق التجارية، طريق البخور
قرية «الفاو» الجميل فيها لما عثروا عليها
عثرت عليها على ما أعتقد «أرامكو»
تعرف لما يروحون للتنقيب عن البترول
يروحون ينزلون مرة عميق عشان الحفر
فعثروا هناك على موقع قرية «الفاو» وبلّغوا عليه
وبدأت فيه التنقيبات جامعة الملك سعود
فهو يعود لمملكة «كندة» عرب مننا وفينا
من السعودية نقول، من الجزيرة العربية
أنا أشبهها في «بومبي»
بغض النظر عن حضارة «بومبي»
لا شك أنا في نظري...
اللي ما يعرفها، لو تعطينهم نبذة
هي أن صار لها عذاب بسبب
يقولون هي الفترة الرومانية، صار لها فساد
بسبب كيف هم كانوا فاسقين وغيرها
بس هي كيف الطريقة اللي عثروا عليها
مثلًا «بومبي» بركان «فيزوف» انفجر
فطاح الرماد عليهم، فكل الناس في مكانهم
مثل ما تقول، مثل ما جاهم الرماد...
هي كانت مشهور بالبغاء أو بالجنس
هي إيه، كانت بلد فساد
فهم يقولون هذا عقوبة اللي جاءتهم
فنفس ما هم الناس في مكانهم
فلما بدأوا يشيلون، والمشكلة الرماد مرة صعب
لما تصير فيه عملية الحفر والتنقيب
لأنه خفيف وعلى طول يطيح
فبعد ما نقّبوا، عثروا على الجدران والرسومات الصخرية
نفس الشيء تقول في قرية «الفاو»
لو تشوف الصور الجوية، بنص الصحراء موجودة، تشوف الجدران
«بومبي» اكتشفوها -على ما أعتقد- بـ 1600 و 1700 ميلادي
فشوف كم سنة وهم ينقبون فيها، فوق الـ 200 سنة
السنة اللي فاتت أو هذه السنة اكتشفوا رسمة جديدة، تخيل
فين؟
في «بومبي»
وين موقعها هي؟ في أي دولة؟
في إيطاليا
وهي أكثر باب...صح أن البركان قتلهم
بس هو السبب أنه حفظ الرسمة مثل ما كانت الأماكن
المباني، لا شك أن السقف دائمًا يطيح، لأنه خشب ومواد عضوية
عندك قرية «الفاو» لما كشفوا عنه وبدأوا
لقوا رسومات جدارية، فيها فوق 13 بئر في المنطقة
بعدين لقوا معبد. فيه على الجدران كمان رسومات
ولما تشوف عملوا إعادة رسم وتصور
باستخدام التقنية لقرية «الفاو»
تحلف أنها بيوت «نجد» اللي موجودة هنا
نفس الطراز، نفس كل شيء، البيوت الطينية
فقرية «الفاو» جدًّا جميلة
الله يغفر له ويرحمه، الدكتور «عبدالرحمن الأنصاري»
عمل أبحاث جدًّا جميلة عنها
بس في هذاك الوقت ما تقدر تحكي بشكل كبير
عن الأشياء اللي موجودة
لكن صار لها فترة مسكّرة قرية «الفاو» ما رجع التنقيب فيها
والدكاترة اللي نقبوا في قرية «الفاو»
مع الدكتور «عبدالرحمن الأنصاري» الله يغفر له
الآن هم نخبة الآثار في المملكة
فحتى شوف قرية «الفاو» اللي تدربوا فيها
الآن هم مثل ما نقول رواد التخصص في المملكة
فحتى تاريخ اللي نقبوا فيها، بحد ذاته حلو لما تجي تحكيها
قرية «الفاو» كانت جدًّا مزهرة بالتجارة
كان فيها استقرار، كانت مملكة غنية، تجار
ومع الأبحاث، إن شاء الله، أنها ترجع
بس أنتِ لما تقارنين بين «بومبي» وبين قرية «الفاو»
أنه اكتشفت قبل 200 سنة، وإلى اليوم فيه اكتشافات جديدة فيها
اللي هي «بومبي»
فمعناته أننا إلى اليوم ما استكملنا رحلة اكتشاف «الفاو»
ومفترض يصير فيها جهد أكبر
ما ندري أيش ممكن نكتشف في هذا المكان
أيوة، وحتى قرية «الفاو» كمية السياحة اللي بتنتجها
أنت لما تجي تسوّق لها، ليش أنا أقول أشوفها مثل «بومبي»
لأن المدينة كاملة عثروا عليها
فلما أنت ترممها وتسوّق لها
الآن في «بومبي» الناس تمشي بين المباني
فممكن نشوف قرية «الفاو» تنتج سياحة للمنطقة
ما فيها شيء، لو تشوفها في وسط البر
فلما أنا أرجع أحيي المنطقة؛ بجذب السياح، يجيني المستثمرين
فيه مواقع أثرية تحيي منطقة كاملة
فأنا أشوف قرية «الفاو» ومملكة «كندة»
ممكن بلا أي شك أنها راح تنفّذ هذا المشروع
اليوم هي محفوظة أو مغلقة؟
إيه مسوّرة
بس ما في أبحاث أو تنقيب فيها؟
عملوا أبحاث كثيرة جامعة الملك سعود ونشروا كثير منها
لكن ما أُستكملت البعثات بعدها، ما أعرف أيش السبب صراحة
لكن أتمنى، ممكن أنا أكون غلطانة
وإن شاء الله، أن فيه أبحاث أكثر قاعدين الآن ينقبون عنها
الغريب أن أهم موقعين أو أقدم موقعين على وصفك
مافي عليها أبحاث، نتكلم عن «الشويحطية»
آخر أبحاث أو تنقيب فيها قبل أربعين سنة؟
إيه
هذا واحد من أقدم المواقع في قارة آسيا كلها؟
بالضبط
وما في أبحاث عليها، شلون؟
والله شوف، أنا للأمانة ما عندي المعلومات
أنا ماني بالجهة المعنية، ما أشتغل فيها
بس أنتِ مهتمة في الموضوع
فأكيد عندك تفسير، شلون أقدم موقع في السعودية ما فيه؟
هذا السؤال اللي أنا أطرحه عليك
كيف احنا عندنا موقع مثل هذا جدًّا مهم
وما رجعنا نعمل أعمال تنقيب فيه
حتى لما توصل له، ما فيه لوحات
فيه كثير مواقع للأسف عندنا
حتى ما في لوحات استرشادية تدلك على الموقع
أنت لما توصل له، مثلًا أي بلد لما تسافر
دائمًا فيه لوح استرشادية، تقولك الموقع كذا في هذا الاتجاه
عندنا مو كل المواقع موجودة، في المملكة بشكل عام
فما في حتى لوح تدلّك!
الحين، الحمد لله، عندنا خرائط قوقل، تقدر تدلّك بشكل أسهل
بس أنك تروح إلى المنطقة، تلقى مو كل المواقع موجودة فيها
بيجي هنا عن سؤال من المجموعة
اللي مو مهتمة كثير في موضوع الآثار
ولا تشوفه شيء مشوّق، طيب وبعدين؟
درينا أن هذه عمرها مليون ونصف سنة
ودرينا أن هذه القرية موجودة من 200 ألف سنة، وبعدين؟
أيش تعني كل هذه الاكتشافات
اللي قاعدة تحكين عنها في الأراضي السعودية؟
هي أصلًا هجرة الإنسان مثل ما قلت لك
العصور الحجرية تمثل أكثر غموض، لأن ما عندك كتابة
فلما أنا أشوف هذه المستوطنات
ممكن نلقى موقع مثلًا
تخيل لو نلقى أقدم من إفريقيا في السعودية، على سبيل المثال
فتعطيني فكرة على الإنسان
طريقة التنقل، الطبيعة كيف كانت في هذيك المنطقة
وتعطيني على العمق التاريخي للهوية السعودية
أنا وأنت اليوم جالسين في السعودية
لما نروح أنا وأنت يوم، إن شاء الله، نشوف النقوش
تعرف أن فيه نقوش تذكر أسامي قبائل
ما زالت موجودة اليوم بالسعودية
وهذه تحكي من 500 سنة قبل الميلاد، 300 سنة، 2000 سنة
فحتى القبائل اللي موجودة
حتى الهوية نفسها لها تاريخ، فتلقى أسامي القبائل موجودة
الحين اسأل أي شخص من أي قبل قبيلة؟
بيقول لك اسمه الين الجد رقم مئة
فهذه توريك الارتباط
هذه الممالك هم احنا، احنا ما جينا فجأة في السعودية
لنا تاريخ ممتد
مثل ما ذكرت، اللي قاله الأمير محمد
احنا مرتبطين بكل هذه الممالك
مملكة «كندة» مملكة «دادان ولحيان» مملكة «قيدار»
كل الممالك اللي موجودة؛ احنا منها
يورّيك عمق الهوية
حتى لما تشوف المناظر، الناس كيف كانوا يصيدون
إلى الآن شيء تشوفه في السعودية
الحمد لله، الجميل عندنا في السعودية من الناحية السياحية
لما الشخص يجي، يشوف...
مثلًا أنت الحين جالس معي لابس ثوب
فتشوف الهوية ما زالت موجودة
مو بمثل بلدان تشوفها إلا إذا رحت للقرى، تشوف الأزياء التراثية
فهويتنا حية
حية ما زالت
تراثنا مستمر
حتى والله لما تشوف بعض الناس يشرحون
تلقاه أحيانًا لابس نفس اللي بالنقش
فيعطيك تصوّر على أنك حافظت كل هذا الألاف من السنين
على الهوية مو بقصد، لأن هذا أنت
هذه هويتك، هذا اللي أنت تعرفه واللي تشوفه
جزء برضه من محتواك في تويتر
يتكلم على أشياء غريبة في السعودية
موضوع أكبر نهر، بحيرتين، فرس النهر
أيش الاكتشافات هذه؟
هذه اسمها الجزيرة العربية الخضراء
هي كانت المملكة قبل مليون سنة
تختلف تمامًا عن الطبيعة اللي نشوفها اليوم
مثل الأودية اللي عندنا «وادي حنيفة» «وادي مساح»
كلها كانت بالسابق من مليون سنة
أنهار جارية
كانت أنهار جارية
في المملكة، تعرف فيه فوق الـ10 آلاف نهر دائم، مو موسمي
عندك في حائل، في «جُبه» فيه كثير عثروا على الأنهار
حتى في الجبل فوق
في صحراء «النفوذ» كمان في حائل
كل هذه الأشياء اكتشفوا فيها أنهار
عندك صحراء «خريص» قبل عشرين مليون سنة كانت بحر
قبل عشرين؟
قبل عشرين مليون سنة
عشرين مليون سنة كانت بحر
كانت بحر، إلى اليوم تشوف فيها أسنان القرش المتحجرة
أنا بنفسي رحت الموقع وشفتها
فهذا كله يعطيك فكر، أنك لما تجي بالعصور الحجرية
تشوف الإنسان دائمًا يدور النهر
وين ما كان؛ ممكن يكون فيه استيطان
فأنا مثلًا لقيت الوادي
ما راح أحفر جوّا الوادي، بحفر جنب الوادي
بس بعدها مثلًا لما يجف النهر؛ ممكن أحفر تحت
فتجيني فترات تكون قريبة أكثر من أنها قديمة
وهذه تعطينا فكر عن الطبيعة الجغرافية للمملكة
كيف نعرف؟ هذه كلها فرضيات
شلون نفترض أن هذه كانت بحيرة؟
وشلون دريتوا أن هذا فرس نهر؟
بس لو تعطينا شرح أكثر
الجميل بعلم الآثار أن هي مظلة فيها كثير من التخصصات
فأكثر الناس نمشي معهم في نفس الخط
نقول الجيولوجيين، الأخصائيين
فيكون معك مختص من اللي يدرس جيولوجيا
فيشوفون من الأحجار، يعرفون من طبقات الأرض
أنت الحين لو تشوف جبل، راح تلاحظ أن فيه طبقات ألوان تختلف
ترى كل هذه فترة زمنية
نفس الشيء، لما احنا نحفر بالآثار، نسميها الطبقات
فلما تشوفها على الجنب، تشوف كل شوية بدأت تتغير التربة
هذه كل وحدة فترة زمنية
فتكون كل فترة تجي، بعدين يجي طبقة، بعدين طبقة
فتكون هذه فترات، نفس الشيء بالجبال
هذه يكونون مختصين في علم الجيولوجيا
هم اللي يدرسونها ويشوفون نوع الأحجار اللي موجودة، الطبيعة
واللي مثلًا على الحيوانات تكون متحجرة، العظام حقتهم موجودة
فرس النهر مثلًا، هذا بالنسبة لي شيء مثير، وشلون؟
هذا كان موجود في صحراء «النفوذ»
اكتشفوا اللي يسمونها الأنهار القديمة
فعلى ما أعتقد، كان من مليون سنة
يمكن الفترة اللي هي «العصر الجليدي الأخير»
من مليون سنة لعشر آلاف سنة
أو خمسين ألف سنة، شيء مثل كذا
فكانت هذه الفترة
طبعًا هذه الفترات تعرفها من الطبقات اللي موجودة؛ الأنهار اللي كانت
فمتى يكون عندك فرس نهر؟
هذا ما كان نهر مؤقت، هذا كان نهر مستمر
لأن الفرس وين بيروح بعدها؟ مو برايح للبر
بيقعد بالمنطقة
فيعطيك تصور أن الطبيعة كانت مختلفة
بعدين تشوف مثلًا في «الدوادمي» اكتشفوا في موقع
فجأة صار فيه طلب على المكاشط، اللي يقصون فيها جلد الحيوانات
فهنا معناتها الجو بدأ يتغير من الرطوبة
كيف فجأة؟
فجأة، أنت تشوف عندك الفترات الزمنية
الأدوات اللي كانت موجودة
هي عبارة عن طبقات
لا، أنت تشوفه في كل موقع، مثلًا «الشويحطية» مليون سنة
ما كان فيه مكاشط بهذا العدد المهول
في «الدوادمي» لقوا آلاف أدوات العصور الحجرية
اللي هي المكاشط اللي يقصون فيها الجلد
هي لا شك موجودة في كل فترة
لكن لما يصير عندك فجأة طلب عليها بشكل كبير
معناته هنا بدأت البيئة تتغير
ما زال مستمر فيه أمطار وأنهار، لكن مو مثل السابق
هنا بدأ الجو يتغير، ويصير أبرد
فصارت الناس تستخدم الجلد أكثر
فهنا مثلًا الأدوات تعطينا دليل، على كيف الطبيعة تغيرت
ففي حقبة زمنية معينة، لاحظتوا زيادة في أدوات كشط الجلود
بالضبط، اللي يطلعون فيها الجلد، يلبسها
فاعتبرتوها علامة على أن الطقس تغير
بالضبط، لأن ليش فجأة يصير فيه طلب على الجلد؟
لأن أول لا شك أنهم لما يجون ياكلون الحيوان
أكيد بيشيلون الجلد، لكن لما فجأة تصير عندك زيادة مهولة على الطلب
هذا يعطيك تصور، هنا الأدوات...
هذا الجميل بعلم الآثار، مثل ما تركب كذا قطع
صحيح
فتصير تشوف، هنا صار عندي زيادة، طيب ليه؟ ليش مو مثلًا قبل؟
مثلًا بـ«بالشويحطية» ليش أنا ما لقيت هذا الطلب؟
فمعناته هنا صار هناك تغير
طيب أخذتوا المعلومة هذه، تربطونها مع مين؟ مع علماء الطقس؟
بالضبط، فهنا تجي مع الجيولوجيا
مو أنه فجأة، طبعًا تغير الجو يأخذ فترات طويلة
فمعناتها مثلًا نقول، صار فيه موسم شتاء بارد مو مثل قبل دافئ
الرطوبة معاد صارت عالية مثل الأول مثلًا
فهذه تعطيك دلالات على التغير اللي قاعد يصير بالطبيعة
وفيه متخصصين يسمونها «العصر الحجري القديم» (Paleolithic) مثلًا يدرسون الأنهار القديمة
الأنهار عمرها مرة قديم
بعدين نجي مثلًا للربع الخالي
الربع الخالي تكوّن، على ما أعتقد قريت لدكتور في «عالم أرامكو»
في مجلة «أرامكو» في الثمانينيات كان إصدار المجلة، على ما أعتقد
كان يقول أن من 2 مليون سنة تكونت صحراء الربع الخالي
كان فيها أنهار، الأنهار ينقسم تكوينها لثلاث فترات
من 37 ألف سنة، وبعدين من 17 ألف سنة
وبعدين من 10 آلاف إلى 5 آلاف سنة
عثروا على بحيرة «المندفن»
العصر الحجري كمان، عثروا على موقع وكان فيها نهر دائم مو موسمي
وين هذه؟
في الربع الخالي
إيه، كان حجمها 300 كيلو متر مربع
حجم البحيرة
وعمقها على ما أعتقد ما يزيد عن 10 متر، ما تقول المهولة
بس كانت مستمرة، لأن فيها استيطان لكذا فترة
ووجود البحيرة معناته فيها سمك، فيها آثار سمك؟
إيه، عثروا
في الربع الخالي؟
حتى جهة الإمارات بالربع الخالي، كمان لقوا فرس النهر
الجهة حق الإمارات
والربع الخالي بحكم طبيعته وصعوبته الآن
فما عندك كثير رحلات استكشافية قاعدة تصير فيه
فلو توسعت ممكن
وكمان هناك اللي يسمونها علم الآثار الفضائي
أنك تقدر تبحث عن المواقع اللي تكون منعزلة
عن طريق الصور الجوية والأقمار الصناعية
الربع الخالي يعتبر غامض، فيه كثير تاريخ
لكن بحكم طبيعته، مو كثير البعثات اللي تصير
صارت لكن مو بشكل كبير
هل فيه شيء مرتبط بثورة زراعية
بما أن المنطقة هذه كان كلها أنهار
فهل كان فيه أي علامات على بدايات الثورة الزراعية كانت من السعودية مثلًا؟
إلى الآن ما عندنا دليل قاطع يقول لك أن الثورة الزراعية
بس فيه فرضيات؟
شوف المشكلة هنا ممكن نقول أن المعلومات مو صعبة
ترى أنا اللي أقول لك إياه
بعض المعلومات أنا بنفسي تواصلت مع اللي نقبوا
البعثات الأثرية، وطلبت منهم الدراسات
مو أن أنا حصلتها بالصدفة
فالمعلومات أنك تلقاها هنا، للأسف مو بشكل كبير موجودة
أنك على طول تكتب في قوقل كذا
إلا إذا البعثة نفسها نشرت
وفيه البعثات القديمة اللي كانت تجي
أحيانًا تنشر في لغتها، ما تنشر حتى بالعربي
ما أعرف أنا شخصيًّا إذا فيه شيء مرتبط
لكن فيه استيطان كان في فترات العصر الحجري موجودة عندنا
وبما أن ما كان فيه اهتمام بقطاع التراث والآثار بشكل عام
يبدو أن كثير من الاكتشافات كانت بالصدفة
عن طريق «أرامكو» جاية تحفر بئر ولقت لها قرية وللا
اليوم فيه شيء يشبه مرحلة تنقيب «أرامكو»
لكن على حجم مشاريع كبرى
فمثلًا البحر الأحمر شغّال في جزر على مساحة ضخمة
«نيوم» شغالة في مواقع أيضًا مهمة
مثلًا حديقة الملك سلمان شغالة في وسط الرياض
وقاعدة تنزل في أعماق كبيرة
هذه المشاريع الكبرى اللي موجودة
«الدرعية» كذلك، وقطعًا بيكون فيها اكتشافات كبيرة
هل قاعدين نستغل هذه الفرصة بأن نوثّق ونهتم
بهذه الاكتشافات أثناء العمل على هذه المشاريع الكبرى؟
إيه، الآن مرة تغيّر
الآن حتى فيه مواقع لنا تجي تحفر
مثلًا تبغى تسوي مشروع، يطلبوا منك تجيب آثاري
يتأكد أن الموقع ما فيه موقع أثري، وأنك ما تدمر شيء
وهذه من الأشياء الجميلة اللي صارت عندنا جديدة
أشوف الظاهر مشروع «السودة» وقّع مع هيئة التراث
إتفاقية أن خلال عملهم في نطاق المشروع
يكون فيه تعاون لحماية أي آثار ممكن تكتشف في الموقع
الآن هذا الجميل، أنت الآن أي مشروع بتسويه ضخم
بيكون في مواقع، لأن الحين كمان قاعدين نطلع على مواقع جديدة
قاعدة تكبر، فمثلًا مثل «السودة» بمواقع ما قد ناس سكنوا فيها
لازم الحين الشرط، أن يكون معاك شخص متخصص في علم الآثار
أنا قابلت أحد المسؤولين في مطار الملك خالد، اللي يبنون الشركة
فكان يقول أن الآن صار عندنا...
كان يسألني يبغون آثاريين، لأنهم قاعدين يوسعون المطار
فلازم شرط أن أحد يتأكد المنطقة ما فيها أي موقع أثري يتدمر
يحفظونها، يدرسونها، وبعدين يشوفون الإجراءات اللي كيف تتم
وهذا شيء جميل صار عندنا
أن ما عاد صار الواحد على طول يبني
لازم يجيب شخص مختص يدرس الموقع
وبعدين إذا قالك ما في شيء؛ تبدأ
جزء من النقاشات اللي تصير عادةً في موضوع الآثار والمواقع هذه
هي دلالاتها في الأسبقية
على سبيل المثال، موضوع اللغة العربية، أصل العرب
نقاط مثل هذه، أيش لقيتوا؟ وأيش اطلعتِ عليه في هذا الخصوص؟
شوف مثلًا أصل العرب، ما يقدر أحد يقول أنا من هنا، أنت من فين
مثلًا ما أقدر أقول لك أن أصل العرب من السعودية
ما في دليل يثبت لي، لأن في النهاية أنت لما تحلل بيطلع لك العظم
ما راح يطلّع لك أيش بالضبط
لأن لازم يكون عندك شيء تقدر تمسكه، تشوفه، لغة أو بغيرها
بس أنت لما تجي تقارن، مثلًا في السعودية
عندنا من 1.3 مليون سنة استمرارية
المملكة بشكل عام فيه استمرارية بالسكن كاملة
بعدين عندك في الممالك، احنا نوازي عمر أقدم مملكة
موجودة في الجزيرة العربية، مملكة «دادان ولحيان» بـ«العُلا»
توازي أيش هذه؟
توازي عمر مملكة «سبأ»
مملكة «دادان ولحيان» توازي عمر مملكة «سبأ»
توازيها بالألف الأول قبل الميلاد
ما أقدر أقولك أن مملكة «دادان» أقدم وللا «سبأ»
حسب آخر الدراسات
وممكن أجيك بعد سنة، تتغير كل هذه الأشياء
لأن الجميل بعلم الآثار، ما عندك كتاب معين ترجع له
فحسب آخر اكتشافات وآخر دراسات تتغير، مثل «نحت الجمل»
ما أحد يقدر يجزم، ويقول لك أصلهم من هنا أو من هنا، مافي دليل قاطع
بس ليش سردية أن أصل العرب من اليمن؟
ليش هذه سائدة وموجودة؟
هي مالها دليل علمي يقطع هذه المقولة
ما في دليل علمي عليها؟
ما عندك دليل
بس أنا ما أقدر أقول لك من وين
الآن لو تسألني كحصة
هل نقدر نقول أيش أقدم نقش عربي موجود؟
هل نقدر نستخدم هذا كدليل؟
كنقش لغة عربية؟
إيه
فيه موجود عندنا بالسعودية، موجودة نقوش
اللي هو الخط الغير منقّط العربي
وين هذه؟
موجودة في السعودية، نسيت صراحة اسم الموقع، بس قريب أعلنوا عنه
فموجودة عندنا
تتذكرين كم كان عمره؟
والله ناسية كم كان عمره، بس ببداية الفترات الإسلامية
حتى عندك في موقع جنب الطائف
فيه منطقة تعتبر من الفترة الإسلامية المبكرة
الخط الغير منقّط
بس الفترة الإسلامية تعتبر قريبة
إيه، لا أنا أقولك مثلًا
مو مقياس، العرب أقدم من الإسلام
إيه. مثل الممالك، إذا بنشوف على تاريخ الممالك
السعودية توازي أقدم عمر، عندنا موجود في «العُلا»
من ناحية استيطان العصر الحجري في السعودية
اللي هو نهضة الانسان اللي بدأ
هي بعد العصر الحجري الحديث اللي فجأة صار فيه تطوّر كبير
فهذه كلها موجودة في السعودية
من عصور ما قبل  التاريخ الحجرية إلى فترة الممالك
فهذه كلها موجودة عندنا
الممالك اللي كانت موجودة في مختلف مناطق المملكة
أنا ما أجزم لك، هم من هنا أو من هنا
لكن ما في دليل يثبت هم من وين
ما بقدر أقول لك، إلى الآن ممكن فيه دراسة أنا ما أعرف عنها شخصيًّا
ممكن، لكن كشخص يجزم لك أنه من هنا؛ ما لها دليل علمي
من الاكتشافات الظاهر مؤخرًا، موضوع الكنيسة في «الجبيل» صحيح؟
إيه. هو مو مؤخرًا، كمان «أرامكو» اكتشفت الموقع
قديمة هذه
إيه، كانت تعود للقرن الرابع الميلادي
والجميل في اكتشاف الكنيسة أنها ما تعرضت إلى التدمير
ما تعرضت لأي شيء، اكتشفوا حوالينها فخار إسلامي
عادي عاشوا بسلام. ما قد تحولت لمسجد
وما زالت موجودة، ولا تعرضت لنهب ولا شيء، موجودة جدرانها
فقط اللي يطيح دائمًا، أول شيء يطيح عندك السقف لأنه خشب، عضوي
فمع الزمن يطيح على طول
يمكن هذا كذا مجرد استعراض سريع
وتنقّل بين المواقع المختلفة عشان المشاهد والمستمع
يقدر يستوعب أيش الكنوز اللي موجودة
الحين ممكن ندخل أكثر على موضوع
التحولات اللي صارت بعد الرؤية
يمكن من أولها وأبرزها في 2017، تأسيس هيئة ملكية لـ«العُلا»
بعدها تأسيس هيئة متخصصة بموضوع التراث
عام  2020 أو 2019 على ما أعتقد
تسجل مجموعة مواقع في الـ«يونسكو»
ففيه حراك، لو نستعرض أبرز ما صار في هذا الحراك
وأيش الشيء اللي نطمح وما بعد صار؟
أهم شيء أقدر أقعد معاك اليوم
ونحكي عن هذا الموضوع بشفافية
نقول صار الواحد يقدر يحكي
لما تشوف القائد نفسه قاعد يحكي لك عن التاريخ
أول ما كان بالشكل، مثل ما تقول بالدّس بس
ما كان الواحد يقدر يحكي بشكل عام عن المواقع الأثرية
هذا صحيح وللا فرضيات؟
لا، أول ما تسمع الناس تحكي عن الاكتشافات اللي صارت
مثلًا أنا ما كنت أقدر أشتغل في هذاك الوقت
فالتغير اللي صار بشكل كبير
أنك تحكي وتقول كذا وكذا،
أول ما تقدر تقول أي شيء، فيه شوي تحفّظات
فنشوف مثلًا الهيئة الملكية بـ«العُلا»
صراحة أنا عندي، من أجمل الهيئات اللي تشتغل بهذا المجال
هي الهيئة الملكية لـ«العُلا»
التغيير اللي صار، كيف قاعدين يسوقون للمواقع الأثرية
دراستها، عدد البعثات الأثرية اللي موجودة
نشرهم حتى للوثائق، تلقى الحين أفلام وثائقية في اليوتيوب
تلاقي يخلونها لأي أحد يقدر يشوفها
الفرق اللي قاعدة تشتغل
برامج التدريب اللي يقدمونها للطلاب من جميع مناطق المملكة
الهيئة الملكية لـ«العُلا» شغلها جدًّا جميل
اكتشفوا، بسبب جهود الهيئة الملكية بـ«العُلا» أقدم استيطان
موجود إلى الآن بـ«العُلا» حوالي 200 ألف سنة
وعدد المواقع اللي وُثّقت من «العُلا» لصحراء «خيبر»
180 ألف موقع. تخيل بس في هذه المنطقة
ومنها اثنين وعشرين من المنشآت الحجرية اللي موجودة
اللي وُثّقت في «العُلا»
المنشآت الحجرية موجودة بكل أنحاء المملكة
بس «العُلا» اللي نقول اشتغلت على شكل أكبر؛ تحصرها
فـ«العُلا» يحكون -مثل ما تقول- لغة الأرقام بالآثار
على الأقل حاصرين، أنت أهم شيء تعرف أنك تحصر
أنا هنا عندي موقع، وهنا موقع، وهنا موقع
عشان كذا وقّفوا الأعمال، لأن لازم...
«العُلا» بدون مبالغة كل مكان فيه أثر
أنا أتذكر جدتي لما تحكي، جدتي من «العُلا» من «الحِجر»
بتقول واحنا صغار، دائمًا واحنا نلعب بالتراب؛ يطلع لنا نتمثال
إن شاء الله، نقول أشياء ما نُهبت
لأنها على وقت الرحالة وغيرها
بس كفاية أنهم سووا الحركة
أنهم وقفوا البناء، ووقفوا التوسع الين ما يوثقون
وقاعدين يبدونها خطوة بخطوة
حصروا، عملوا مسح آثري هنا؛ يروحون للمنطقة اللي بعدها
حتى طريقتهم جدًّا مرتبة، مرة منظمة
بالنسبة لكثير من السعوديين وغير السعوديين اللي يتابعون السعودية
يعرفون أن «العُلا» فيها شيء قديم، وفيه اهتمام فيه
بس كتفاصيل، كحكاية مو معروف
أيش هو هذا الشيء للبعض، يمكن البعض يعرفون
أيش اللي موجود في «العُلا»؟
«العُلا» يعود فيها أقدم طبقات الأرض، اللي هي 500 مليون سنة
اللي يسمونها فترة «الكامبري»
فـ«العُلا» حتى كموقع من الأقدم في العالم
فأنت تحكي موجودة كتشكلات صخرية وغيرها
«العُلا» فيها حتى القصص التراثية
أتذكر جدتي تحكي لنا، لما كنا نروح معاها
أول تدخل «مدائن صالح» بالسيارة الين القبر، عادي
ما في مشكلة
ما في مشكلة، فكان يقولون إن فيه قصر البنت
فلما نشوفها من بعيد في فوقه كذا مثل شباك، ما اكتمل
كذا مثل غرفة صغيرة وتحتها حجرة
فكانت تقول أن هذا قصر الصانع، وكانت بنت الصانع تحب الخباز
ولما أبوها درى حطها فوق
سجنها فوق
بالضبط، سجنها
فكانت هي ترمي شعرها ويجي الخباز ويوقف على الحجرة
وكان يربط خيله هناك
فتتشوف التشكلات بـ«العُلا» فالحجرة بالنص نحيفة
ومن فوق مثل شكل الفطر كذا
فكان عشان الحصان مرة يدور؛ صارت ضيقة، لأنه يستنى
فكانت ترمي شعرها، كان اسمها «بثينة»
فهو يقول لها قصيدة، نسيت القصيدة صراحة
فأبوها درى من الخدامة اللي تشتغل عندها
كانت تقول «يا ويل الحدري لو يدري، وبثينة عشّرت بدري»
فعرف، بعدين قتلها، فتشوف أنه مثل الثلاثة خطوط دم
فيقول قتلها هي والخباز اللي تحبه وولدها
ويقولون لك ممكن مو أكيد، كمان الخدامة اللي كانت عندها
بعد الدراسات ولما صرت أدرس علم آثار
واكتشفت أن «الأنباط» كانوا يبدؤون البناء من فوق إلى تحت
إذا شخص توفّى أو ما عنده فلوس أو غيرها؛ يوقفون البناء
فلا هي «بثينة» وللا شيء، بس هنا القصص
حلوة القصص الشعبية اللي تجي من التراث الغير ملموس
بس هذه تنتمي لأي مرحلة؟
والله هذه على فترة جدتي
لا أقصد، هذه الآثار
«الأنباط»
«الأنباط»؟
إيه
سولفي لنا عنهم للي ما يعرفوا «الأنباط»
«الأنباط» كانوا جدًّا مشهورين بالتجارة
فكان عاصمتهم «البتراء» بالأردن، وفيه عندك امتدت لمناطق كبيرة،
وفيه بـ«العُلا» وفيه كمان بالجوف
بالجوف كانت منطقة عسكرية أكثر
بسبب أن لما شافوا النقوش، فيه لقب عسكري كان يكون قبل الإسم
فكانت المنطقة في الجوف تقول عسكرية أكثر
وفيه عندنا مينائين قديمة لـ«الأنباط» على البحر الأحمر
«الأنباط» وصلوا لإيطاليا، وكان فيه عندهم منطقة هم ساكنين فيها
وكان فيها حتى معبد «نبطي» اكتشفوه الآن وهو تحت البحر
فـ «الأنباط» اشتهروا بالتجارة
كانوا مثل ما تقول، هم اللي محركين كل المناطق، بري وبحري
فكانوا مو فقط على مستوى بري
كانوا يسافرون ويروحون لمناطق بعيدة ويجون
حتى الموانئ القديمة، لأن فيه مثلًا بضائع تقول لك ما أبي أدخل
لأن كان فيه ضرائب أول، فيكتفون
ففيه عند الموقع عن جهة «نيوم» ميناء قديم
فهناك كان فيه سوق، وهناك تجي التجارة والناس تبيع ويتاجرون وغيرها
فهذه مملكة «الأنباط» اللي عاصمتها «البتراء»
أيوة
وممتدة من «العُلا» جنوبًا إلى إيطاليا شمالًا
بالظبط، بس إيطاليا كانوا مستوطنين فقط، ما كانت تابعة لهم
بس بحكم أنهم كثار، مثل التجار يكون عندهم مكان هنا ومكان هنا
فبحكم سفرهم كثير لإيطاليا
كان لهم مواقع هناك
إيه، بعدين الرومان استولوا عليهم 106 ميلادي
وتعتبر «الأنباط» أقدم وللا «دادان ولحيان»؟
لا، «دادان ولحيان» على الألف الأول قبل الميلاد
وأيش قصتهم؟
«دادان ولحيان» من الممالك القديمة
اللي كانت موجودة في الجزيرة العربية
اشتهروا نفس الشيء في التجارة، وكانوا على طريق البخور
وقبل على طريق القوافل على ما أعتقد
فـ«دادان ولحيان» هم أول  أول ناس حفروا الجبال بالجزيرة العربية
فالحين تشوف بـ«العُلا» إذا زرت الموقع
«الخريبة» على ما أعتقد اسمها
فيه اللي يسمونها «مقابر الأسود»
فالقبور حافرينها وفيه فوقها تماثيل
طبعًا مو مثل إتقان «الأنباط» هم جاوا بعدهم
بس أن فيه تماثيل منحوتة
حتى فيه عندهم اللي يسمونه كانوا محلب الناقة
كان حجر رملي كامل حافرينه
كان يعبونه موية، كبير
فكان هذا حافرينه جوّا المعبد، وجوّاته درج
فكان لطقوس دينية
فكانت مملكة متقدمة
كثير من ملوكها استولوا لفترة على «تيماء»
على ما أعتقد، لأربعة عشر سنة ملك «لحيان»
واستمرت وبعدين سقطت بعدما جاوا «الأنباط»
صارت حروب وبعدين راحت
بس مملكة «دادان ولحيان» كانت مملكة جدًّا متقدمة ومتطورة
والآن كل يوم قاعدين نسمع زيادة
في اللي قاعدين يعملون فيها الهيئة ملكية
كانت، على ما أعتقد، تنقّب فيها جامعة الملك سعود
والآن الهيئة الملكية لـ«العُلا»
حتى التماثيل اللي اكتشفوها، الحين عارضينها بـ«اللوفر»
لملوك مملكة «لحيان»
فحتى التقدم في النحت، هذا يعطينا كلنا تشكّل على...
أنت دائمًا تدرس المجتمع
فهذا المجتمع كان متقدم، كان متطور
أول من حفر الجبل إلى الآن موثّق؛ لمملكة «دادان ولحيان»
وأظن جزء من نجاح تجربة «العُلا»
والهيئة الملكية «العُلا» بقيادة الأمير بدر
أضيف لها أيضًا نطاق «خيبر» و«تيماء»
أصبحت ضمن نطاق الهيئة الملكية لـ«العُلا»
أيش القيمة التاريخية أو أيش القصص اللي في«خيبر» و«تيماء»؟
شوف عندك «تيماء» مثلًا ينقبون فيها من زمان
أتوقع لعشرين موسم أو لخمسة عشر موسم، فريق ألماني
فهم إلى الآن مو فاهمين «تيماء» هي كانت مملكة وللا إمارة؟
لسه مو واضح
أيش الفرق بين المملكة والإمارة؟
المملكة أنت عندك مملكة كاملة تسيطر
مستقلة
هي الإمارة، تكون إمارات صغيرة موجودة
فهم لسه مو عارفينها، ما فيه شيء عندك اللي يوثّق
أن ملك «بابل» «نابونيدس» جاء لفترة
لعشر سنين استقر في «تيماء» وفيه نقوش
و«تيماء» كانت مرتبطة في «وادي النيل» في مصر
كان فيه تجارة على هذا الخط
كيف مرتبطة بنهر «النيل»؟
طريق «وادي النيل» كان فيه تجارة بين «تيماء» ومصر
وهناك عثروا على النقش «الهيروقليفي»
كمان «تيماء» المميز فيها، ويعكس لك التقدم اللي كانوا فيه
فيه بئر «هدّاج» هذا من أكبر الأبار على مستوى الجزيرة العربية
الأجمل في البئر، أنه ما كان فقط للناس هي تشرب منه
كان بئر «هدّاج» لما يرفعون الموية مئة جمل ياخذ
ولما يرفع؛ اكتشف عليها قنوات مائية تسقي المزارع
فكانت واحات كثيرة «تيماء»
حتى لما عملوا الحفر، لقوا كثير من الفواكه
وكثير من الخضروات اللي موجودة، يعطيك تشكّل
وعمر البئر، على ما أعتقد، من 3000 قبل الميلاد إلى 2000 قبل الميلاد
وحتى سور المدينة قبل ما يأتي الملك «نابونيدس» البابلي
فالمدينة من زمان موجودة وفيها سكانها
واستمرارية بالاستيطان على مدينة «تيماء»
زرتيها أنتِ؟
«تيماء» لا، صراحة ما رحت لها، بس رحت «العُلا»
أنا زرت «تيماء» بداية السنة هذه
وشفت برضه ضمن المواقع، إذا ماني بغلطان، معبد قديم
طبعًا شفنا البئر وشفنا كذا موقع
لكن من المواقع معبد قديم، وحكوا عن أن له تاريخ جدًّا عميق
بس أنا ما أذكر المعلومات، بس بما أنك ما زرتيه، يمكن ما تعرفين
هو فيه معبد يعود للملك «نابونيدس» بناه
يمكن أنه هو
إيه، فيه معبد الملك
واللي قدامه تشكيلات صخرية عملاقة
إيه، على ما أعتقد هو
وبعدين ملك «لحيان» استولى على «تيماء» مدة أربعة عشر سنة
شلون أكثر وحدة مهتمة بالآثار ما راحت «تيماء» لسه؟
فيه كمان عندي قرايب من «تيماء»
بس والدتي دائمًا تروح «تيماء» راحت كثير
دائمًا لما أروح لـ«العُلا» تصير قد ما فيه أشياء تبغى تشوفها
فأنسى أني أروح «تيماء» فيروح الوقت وأنا بـ«العُلا»
بس، إن شاء الله، ناوية أروح حائل، الجوف
إن شاء الله، هذه السنة ناوية كلها بس بالسعودية
هو صراحة أتذكر لما رحنا لها؛ كانت المشكلة هي موضوع المسافة
من «العُلا» إلى «تيماء» الظاهر كانت ثلاث ساعات أو أربع ساعات
إيه، تقريبًا
فمشوار طويل ولسه هي توّها تبدأ تتشكل مواقعها التاريخية
رحنا «تيماء» وفي يوم آخر رحنا «خيبر»
فأيش الحكاية في «خيبر»؟
«خيبر» هي اللي فيها أكثر شيء المنشآت الصخرية اللي موجودة
طبعًا هذه المنشآت تعود لعصور مختلفة
فيه منها العصر البرونزي، وفيه منها الحجري الحديث
وفيه منها المستطيل اللي يسمونها المذيّبات، المذيّلات
وفيه الدوائر الركامية وتختلف
فيه منها كانت تعتبر مدافن، فيه منها كانت تعتبر الطقوس الدينية
إلى الآن ما فيه شيء يجزم لك، وفيه منها كانت مصائد
كيف عرفوا أنها مصائد للحيوانات؟
طبعًا غير أنهم اكتشفوا العظام
لقوا نقش، راسمها رسمة على الجبال
نفس اللي موجودة راسمينها وجواتها حيوانات
أوه!
فهذه ربطوها أنها خلاص مصيدة كانت للحيوانات
طبعًا العدد المهولي اللي موجودة
أنت تحكي بـ«خيبر» بـ«العُلا» موجود 22 ألف
ترى «نجد» فيها كثير، مئات الألاف حوالين المملكة
إذا كنا نقول مثلًا 30% منها مصائد
أنت مستوعب بحجم الحيوانات اللي كانت موجودة
الطبيعة كيف كانت
هذه كلها تعطينا دلالات
والمنشآت كبيرة ضخمة
حتى لما تشوفها بالصور الجوية
مثلًا على «خيبر» فيه براكين
على نزلة البركان كلها تلقى المستطيل
فالفكرة أن الجماعات قدرت تبني منشآت صخرية بهذا الحجم؛ يخوّف
أنت تحكي الحجر مو صغيرة، كبيرة
وهنا كان فيه نوع من التشكيك
بأن جهد الإنسان البشري الأول معدوم الإمكانيات
كان فيه فرضيات أو بعض الناس شطحوا
لأن حجمها ودقتها؛ لا تتناسب مع اجتهاد إنسان بسيط
فبعض الناس شطحوا وقالوا فضائيين وما أدري أيش
وبعض الناس تكلموا عن وجود الآلة ووجود حضارة اندثرت
أو صار شيء وانقطع، أيش التفسير؟
شوف هي المشكلة أن الناس مرة تستهين بالإنسان القديم
أنها تشوفه إنسان غير متطور
لولا الإنسان من 3000 سنة قبل الميلاد في العراق
ما اكتشف العجل؛ ما كان عندنا سيارة اليوم مثلًا
فاحنا ما نقيس الناس القديمة
أننا نفكر دائمًا
لأن كمان عندك التصوير دائمًا بالأفلام الكرتون واحنا صغار
«فلنستونز» وما أعرف أيش
تصوّر لك إياهم أنهم ناس غير متطورة
إنسان الكهف يعني متخلف جدًّا
بالضبط، لكن بالعكس
أنا وأنت لو الحين بنروح لهذاك الفترة؛ أول من بيموت
ما راح نقدر، بس هم لو جونا عادي بيستمرون
الحياة جدًّا صعبة
أن الإنسان أخذ كم مليون سنة أنه يوصل للتطور
هذا يعكس لك صعوبة الحياة
ليش الإنسان طوّر أن يتطور؟
هذه مرة ثانية أقول، نظريات ما عندنا كتابة تجزم
لكن المنشآت الصخرية حتى عندك في حايل، في «نجد»
وموجودة حتى عند «الغاط»
أنتِ مرة شغالة تسويق للجماعة
قبل ما تنزل لـ«الغاط» فوق فيه
بس أنها بشكل عام موجودة، في كل مكان منتشرة
حتى أحيانًا أنا لما أطفش أفتح صور الأقمار الصناعية
ومسوية عليها علامات
كميتها مو بطبيعية والأحجام ضخمة
وموجودة مو بس في السعودية
موجودة في كذا منطقة حول العالم
لكن أكبر عدد موجود في السعودية
ما تم حصرها إلى الآن، لكن أعرف أن فيه مشروع
قاعدين يسوونه، أنه راح يتم حصرها
فحتى دراستها، ليش هذا الشكل مثلًا؟
هل هي متصلة باتجاه معين مع نجم أو شيء؟ مرتبط بالفلك؟
فحتى هذا الموضوع جدًّا جميل
لما أنت تشوف هذا العدد والأحجار وطولها
أنا انصدمت لما أشوف الأطوال شيء مهول
حتى اللي بنوه ما كان عددهم شخص، شخصين
فكان فيه جماعات كبيرة مستمرة في هذه المنطقة
ومعناتها «خيبر» ما كانت بالصحراء اللي نعرفها اليوم، فيه حيوانات
الموضوع شوي بعيد، بس على عمق الهوية
فيه نقش عثروا عليه في بادية الأردن «صفوي»
«صفوي» من 200 قبل الميلاد أو 200 ميلادي أو شيء مثل كذا
عثروا كاتب فلان بن فلان صاد حمار وحشي في «نجد»
فحتى عمر «نجد» تشوف الاسم قد أيش عمره
كان فيه حمار وحشي؟
تخيّل كان فيه حمار وحشي في «نجد»
أوه!
حتى ترى النعام كانت منقوشة
منقوشة كذا؟
إيه «الصفوي» موجود في بادية الأردن، على ما أعتقد في شمال الأردن
فشوف، حتى الاسم «نجد» إلى اليوم احنا نقول «نجد»
حتى الأسامي اللي عندنا
أنا أقول لك العمق التاريخي للسعودية جدًّا عميق
وقبل ما أقفل موضوع «العُلا»
أبغى أسألك عن تغيير مسمى «مدائن صالح» إلى منطقة «الحِجر»
أيش الفكرة؟
صراحة ما عندي خلفية كبيرة عن هذا الاسم ليش تغيّر
لكن يمكن كان متعارف أكثر
كان يقول لنا الدكتور «تؤخذ الأسامي بعلّتها ولا تعلّل»
مو كل اسم له تفسير، أحيانًا كذا
مثل «الرجاجيل» مو معناته له قصة في رجل معين
فهي على ما أعتقد طالع لارتباط الموقع
هي «صالح» صح الاسم، بس على ما أعتقد في الفترة العثمانية
أو الإسلامية اللي قبل، كان شخص اسمه «صالح» ماسك المنطقة
فتغيّر لـ«الحِجر»
لأن أصلًا «الأنباط» مسمينها «هجرة»
«هجرة»؟
إيه «الحِجر»
فهي ما هي مربوطة بموضوع النبي صالح؟
لا، مو مربوطة
ومنطقة العذاب؟
حسب علمي لا صراحة
أقول لك في الآثار ما عندي دليل يجزم لي، بس حسب مثلًا
لأن فيه أسامي قريبة، بس تكون تشابه
حتى في السعودية بشكل عام
كثير عندنا مناطق مسميه بأسماء أشخاص
لكنها مو معناه أن لها سبب
يمكن شخص مشهور كان موجود في هذه المنطقة
وحدة من التغيّرات الجوهرية في موضوع التراث والآثار
أنتِ لك تغريدة في 11 يوليو 2011
أيش رأيك؟ واصلين الين 11 يوليو 2011
عندك تغريدة تقولين
يجب أن تكون وزارة الآثار منفصلة عن وزارة السياحة
مهامهم تختلف عن بعض كليًّا، أو شيء مثل هذا
فصلوها
أبشرك انفصلوا، وصار هيئة الآن للتراث تحت وزارة الثقافة
كيف تقيمين عملهم؟
الحين صار فيه وعي أكثر نقول بشكل عام بالآثار
هو أصلًا أنت تفصلها
شوف احنا نتقاطع مع السياحة
مثلًا تجي جهة الآثار وتاخذ الموقع تدرسه، توثقها، ترمّمه
وبعدين تسلّمه للسياحة
هنا السياحة تسوّق له، مثل تقول وكالة تسويق
فالسياحة تقوم بتسويق الموقع
احنا نتوافق معهم، لكن شغلنا يختلف تمامًا
فالسياحة هي تسوّق لك المواقع، لكن أنت شغلك يختلف تمامًا
ما تقدر تربطهم تحت مظلة
فيه كثير بلدان عندهم وزارة السياحة والآثار
لكن الشغل تلقاهم لما تدخل المبنى منفصل تمامًا
فالحمد لله، هذه صارت
إيه، الحمد لله
وتم إنشاء هيئة متخصصة بالتراث
كيف تقيمين أعمالهم الفترة الماضية؟
والله أعمالهم صار فيها تطور للأمانة
صار فيه تغيّرات، صرنا نسمع عن المواقع الأثرية اللي قاعدة تصير
صار فيه مبادرات قاعدة تصير بشكل أكبر بالمواقع الأثرية
الدراسات قاعدة تنتشر نوعًا ما
لكن أنا أشوف عدد البعثات الأثرية ما زال قليل بالمملكة
أنا أتذكر في حلقة الدكتور «جاسر»
كان يقول لنا على حدود خمسة وأربعين بعثة؟
إيه، بس أنت تحكي على حجم المملكة
خمسة وأربعين بعثة
ممكن أنا أكون غلطانة، لكن أنا أشوف اللي اكتشف بالمملكة
ما يجي 10% أو 5%
تخيل أن «العُلا» على مستوى صغير
قاعدين دراسات، ولسه كل يوم قاعدين يكتشفون شيء جديد
وللأسف، احنا في السعودية بحكم الجو مرتبطين
أن احنا بس ننقب بالشتاء
لأن صعب أن تطلع حفريات بالصيف
فهذا شيء مو في يدنا، لكن احنا مرتبطين في موسم معين
لكن عدد خمسة وأربعين ما زال جدًّا قليل، بحكم حجم المملكة
الآن عدد البعثات قليل، بينما اللي فهمت أنا أن لو فتحنا المجال أكثر
للبعثات السعودية ممكن نقدر نوسع العدد
زائد لو فتحنا الباب للآخرين
هل لازم كل بعثة احنا ندفع لها عشان تجي؟
وللا فيه ناس عندهم حافز يجون على حسابهم، ويقوموا بهذه المهمة؟
الآن صار عندنا بالسعودية ست جامعات تدرّس آثار، على ما أعتقد
أنا أتذكر جامعة الملك سعود كانت تسوي تنقيبات أثرية
ما أعرف إذا لسه تسوي
فهي نفسها تصير مثلًا دائرة الآثار
هي اللي تقسّم المواقع على البعثات
أنا ما أعرف صراحة كيف الإجراء هذا قاعد يصير
كيف ما تعرفين؟ إذا أنتِ ما تعرفين مين يعرف؟
والله ما أعرف صراحة كيف الطريقة اللي قاعدة تصير
أنا ماني مع الجهات المعنية
فما عندي خلفية كيف الطريقة قاعدة تصير
فاللي أعرفها أنه مثلًا...
بس أنتِ عندي قبعة ثانية، ترأسين جمعية
إيه، جمعية
معنية بالعاملين في هذا المجال
لما إن شاء الله، ربِّ يفتحها لنا وننقب ونعمل
لسه ما بديتوا؟
لا، لسه
ليش؟
جمعية جديدة، توّنا في مرحلة البداية
بس من علاقاتك في القطاع
هل اليوم المختصصين في الجامعات السعودية
ما عندي علاقات في القطاع في السعودية كثير
بحكم أني ما كنت موجودة على فترات قبل
والله ما أعرف صراحة هنا، أقولك أنا جديدة هنا
ما أعرف كيف طريقة التشريعات اللي تصير
كيف التنظيمات حق التنقيبات، لسه لأنها جديدة
بس هل أقدر أقدّم ترخيص؟
أعرف أنك تقدر تقدم ترخيص
لأنه موجود في الموقع، التقديم على ترخيص
قد جربتي تقدمين أو شيء؟
لا، صراحة لسه ما جربت
بس كيف الطريقة تصير؟
هي كمان صعبة أنت تفتحها لكل أحد على طول يجي
في أي بلد في العالم، فيه لازم مسح أمني طبعًا لا شك فيه
أنت تشرط عليهم اللي تبغاه
فبحكم خبرتي اللي أعرفه، أن فيه كثير بعثات تجي
هي عندها أحد يدعمها. فتجيك معاهد كثيرة من مختلف البلدان
تقولك أنا أبغى تصريح
أنا مثلًا أبغى أعمل حفرية بهذا الموقع
فأنت أول شيء تسويه، ترسل من عندك أحد يكون مسؤول
يراقب أن الأشياء مثل ما هي
حتى لو البعثة محلية لازم يكون فيه شخص
من الجهة المعنية يكون موجود بالموقع
فهم اللي يسوون كل الدراسات وكل شيء وينشرونها
وأنت تحط الشروط اللي تبغاها
حسب اللي أنا أعرفه واللي أشوفه
مو كل البعثات أنت تدفع لها، كثير بعثات تجي
لأن ترى السعودية، أنت مستوعب لو أنا بعثة جيت
هذه جنة لأي عالم آثر
لأن أي شيء بتكتشفه بينتسب لك، ما أحد جاء قبلك نقّب
حتى لو بتكتشف موقع ما يعتبر نادر
بس بيقولون أول بعثة نقبت
بس هذا الكلام ما يتطابق مع سالفة أن ما عندنا إلا خمسة وأربعين بعثة
إذا احنا جنة، كان كلام امتلت الجنة بالبعثات
ليش ما في إلا خمسة وأربعين؟
أنا صراحة ما عندي الجواب
أيش تفسيرك؟
والله ما أدري صراحة، أنا أقولك للأمانة أنا ما عندي خلفية
أيش توصيتك؟
لو أحد يسمعنا اليوم صاحب قرار، أيش توصيتك؟
لازم نزيد عدد البعثات الأثرية
وإذا قالوا لك ما عندنا ميزانيات؟
مو بلازم ميزانية، هي فيه بعثات تجيك
هي بس تطلب منك التصريح والإذن، لأن هي مدعومة
فأنت من جهتك تعطي التصريح والترخيص
أن البعثة تجي وتنقّب وتحط
لأن مثل ما قلت، شخص موجود من الجهة، يشرف على المنطقة
كيف الطريقة اللي قاعدة تصير
وفيه بلدان، حتى تقسيمة ترى
المواقع
صعبة كل شيء من الرياض
لازم أنت تفتح مثلًا دائرة آثار للجنوب، للشمال، لكل موقع
وهذه الدوائر فيه فريق ميداني يسوي مسح
أنت على الأقل تحصر، تضمن المواقع، تبدأ بالأولوية
مثلًا، موقع الحين بيتدمر، جنب سيل، أو جنب كذا
أو فيه شيء منه طايح، أو موقع كثير يصير فيه تخريب
فأنت هنا يجي دورك، تتعاون
يصير أول شيء منها توظيف المجتمع
عندك، ما شاء الله، كثير تخصص آثار في السعودية موجودين
عندك الكادر العلمي الكافي أنك تسويها
فأنا لما أحط في كل منطقة أوزعها؛ أحصر، على الأقل أعرف
ناس تروح على طول للعمل الميداني، المسوحات، الدراسات
أهم شيء حصر المواقع
بدايةً الحلقة لا تتناسب مع اللي واصلينه اليوم
بداية الحلقة نتكلم على كنوز وآثار تاريخية عظيمة
والآن وسط الحلقة، قاعدين نتكلم على جهد مخيّب في عدد البعثات
شوف نكون منصفين، ما نعرف هل فيه؟
أنا للأمانة ما عندي خلفية للإستراتيجية حقتهم، كيف الطريقة
مثلًا خطة للسنة الأولى، خطة للسنة الثانية، خطة للسنة الثالثة
أنا ما أعرف
والله إذا أنتِ الشغوفة بهذا الملف ما تعرفين، من يعرف؟!
يمكن قل جهد مني، نكون منصفين
يمكن أنا قل جهد مني ما أعرف، بس كمان مو واضحة
مثلًا «العُلا» إذا تسألني أقول لك «العُلا» بالعكس
عدد البعثات يتوافق مع المكان وطريقة...
على الأقل «العُلا» قاعدة تحصر
قاعدة تسوي مسوحات جوية، لأن «العُلا» هذه تلقاها منشورة
مو بحكم أن لي علاقاتي بـ«العُلا» أو غيرها، ما لها دخل
هذه كلها تلقاها على الإنترنت ومن قبل، وأنا أكتب عن «العُلا»
بس لما نجي نشوف مثلًا الجهات الثانية
أنا ما أعرف، أكيد أنهم عملوا مثلًا مسح جوي، لا شك
لكن هل وثّقوها ونشروها؟ أنا ما أعرف
أقول لك ممكن قل جهد مني أن أنا ما أعرف
بس حسب اللي أنا أعرفه، ما في العدد
تلقى كثير ناس يرسلون لي
بلغنا على هذا الموقع ما في أحد جاء، بلغنا على هذا الموقع، حرام
وفيه ناس لسه ما زالت قاعدة تاخذ
فاحنا أهم شيء نحتاجه قبل ما ننقّب أصلًا
نحتاج زيادة الواعي عن أهمية الآثار
عدم العبث فيها، ما تاخذها، فيه ناس عندها متاحف خاصة
ماخذه قطع مرة مهم
فأنت أهم شيء على مستوى تحصر القطع
تسوي أشياء ترويجية، تشجع الناس تسلّم القطع
مبادرات، هذا أنا عندي أهم، من قبل التنقيب
ربطًا بهذا الموضوع، وحدة من أهداف برنامج التحول الوطني
هدف استراتيجي وهو المحافظة على تراث المملكة
الإسلامي والعربي والوطني، والتعريف به
مؤشر قياس الأداء، إجمالي عدد مواقع التراث الوطني القابل للزيارة
كان خط الأساس 241، هدفنا في 2020، 447 موقع
آخر التقرير في 2022 وصلنا 350 موقع
احنا الآن في عام 2022 ولا وصلنا لهدف 2020
فواضح أن فيه...
أنت تخيل «خيبر» 180 ألف
«خيبر»؟
من «العُلا» لـ «خيبر» سووا مسح لـ 180 ألف موقع
180 ألف موقع؟
180 ألف موقع، فـ 300 مرة قليل
لو 300 ألف معقول، بس 100 ألف!
ومع ذلك ما حقق، بس هم يقصدون هنا مواقع قابلة للزيارة
بمعنى أنها جُهزت بشكل مبدئي بحيث أنها تزار كمواقع سياحية
جزء من تساؤلات الأصدقاء، مرتبطة بموضوع مثل ما أنت تفضلتي تو
سكان المناطق والمحافظات
أحيانًا هم شايفين آثار وشايفين مواقع مهمة
بس ما هم عارفين أيش مفروض يسوون؟ لمن يبلغون؟
أو أيش مفروض الخطوة اللي يسوونها؟
فيه مثلًا شخص كتبت عنه، الناس إذا راحت لتغريداتي بتلقاه
هو وأبناءه، عياله صغار ما يتجاوزون الـخمسة عشر أو ستة عشر سنة
وثّق 64500 نقش في «العُلا»
64 ألف؟
إيه
واو!
و 400 نقش أو أكبر، بهذا العدد
صراحة نسيت الرقم كم بالضبط، بس في هذا المستوى
تخيل هو وأطفاله، وأرسل لي الصور، وسلّمها لـ«العُلا»
كانت بالعمل مع «العُلا»
فهنا «العُلا» حفزت المجتمع المحلي على التوثيق
وشوف مهما كنت مختص، الشخص أبخص بأرضه
أتذكر مرة كنا قاعدين نتعلم بالأردن على فيزياء الأرض
فأنت تمشي في جهاز يرسل إشارات
وبعدين يرجعها إذا اصطدم في جدار، فيعلمك أن هنا جدار
يختصر لك كثير من الوقت
فيقول مرة رحت موقع وجبت أجهزتي
وقعدت يمكن أربعون دقيقة أجهّز بس الجهاز
ما عمري فكرت أحكي مع المزارع حق المنطقة
كان على ما أعتقد في منطقة بريطانيا
فقال مسكت الجهاز وقعدت أمشي، ولا فكّرت أحكي مع الرجال
قام قال له الرجال، مطوّل؟ أبي أكمّل شغل
قال له معليش أنا الحين قاعد أسوي
قال له أيش تدوّر؟ قال له الجهاز
قام وقّف، وقال له يبدأ من هنا الجدار، ويمتد لمدري كم متر هناك
قال له أنا لو اختصرت على نفسي أربعين دقيقة
وسألت المختص
وعلى طول سألته، لأنها أرضه
صاحب الأرض إيه
وهو كمان لما يحرث إلا ما يصطدم، أكيد أنه عارف
فالسكان المحليين دليل جدًّا مهم عن الأقل كدلالة
يقولون لك لقينا موقع، أيش المفروض نسوي؟
يرسلون إيميل
يرسلوه لمين؟
للجهات المعنية المسؤولة، ممكن كمان المحافظات تساعد
الإمارات اللي موجودة بالمنطقة
لما تكون أنت في محافظة «الغاط»
برضه «الغاط» أنتِ تسويق كل ربعك الحلقة ذي، أيوة؟
بس بشكل عام تكون في المحافظة
شوف هي للأمانة كثير محافظات متعاونة
كثير أنا ما توقعت، فيه أنا تواصلت مع محافظة
قالوا اللي تبونه بنوفره، بس سوّوا الموقع مثلًا
فالمحافظات تساعد، على الأقل تحصر
ممكن، إن شاء الله، بالمستقبل إذا صارت فرصة
هل فيه حافز للي يبلغون؟
والله ما أعرف
ما تعرفين
مجموعة من أسئلة الأصدقاء، ممكن ناخذ إجابات عليها باختصار
موضوع خطوات التنقيب، أيش خطوات التنقيب؟
طبعًا تختلف حسب العصر
إذا كنت تتنقب مثل ما قلنا في البداية عن عصر حجري
فأنت العصور القديمة تنقّب على طول عند سطح الأنهار
إذا تنقّب فيه دلالات عامة تكون مثل المباني وغيرها
فأول خطوة تسويها، تحصر الموقع
وبعدين تبدأ طبقة طبقة تشيلها
الين ما تنزل للأرض اللي يسمونها البذرة الأساسية
فتقعد تنقّب، وتدوّر طبقة طبقة توثقها
حتى لو لقيت حجرة كبيرة في الزاوية
تكتب زاوية الشمال، الشرق كذا
فهي دقيقة جدًّا عملية التنقيب
وكل شيء أول ما تلقاه؛ يتصور في وقتها
لو لقيت جرة في شكل معين، أو طلع لك قبر في شكل معين
لازم توثقها وتصورها
حتى كنا كل ما نخلّص طبقة، يجي المصور يصورها، نوثقها
أهم شيء تكتب
مثل نظام حديقة «الجيراسية» كذا بالفرشاة تقعدون تمشون وللا تحفير؟
لا، بالفرشاة
بالفرشاة، أوه!
بالفرشاة إذا لقيت مثلًا رسمة، لقيت شيء ممكن عظم
لقيت فخار ممكن ينكسر، فتوخّر عنه
هذه الأشياء اللي تكون قابلة أن تنكسر بسهولة
فتكون تستخدم الفرشاة
ومين عادةً اللي موجودين في الموقع؟
بيكون فيه رئيس البعثة، اللي هو الدكتور المسؤول عن البعثة
فيه يكون عندك الرسام أو المصور
حسب البعثة اللي أنت...
فمثلًا إذا بتكون عصور ما قبل للتاريخ، الفريق يختلف
حسب الفترة الزمنية يتم التقديم
بس عندك المختصين
فيه العمال اللي يساعدونك بالتراب لما تجي تشيله
لأن لازم تكبّه في منطقة ثانية
لأن أنت قاعد تحفر، فالتراب اللي يطلع
ففيه فريق عمال
فهذه كلها تختلف على حسب العصر
أيش أهم التقنيات اللي صارت في هذا المجال
وقاعدة تختصر وقت وترفع الدقة؟
أهم شيء هو التصوير الجوي مرة، لأن...
الدرون؟
إيه، الدرون وحتى فيه برنامج
شوف هو مشكلة كمان للآثاريين بشكل عام بالعالم
أن هما يستنون التكنولوجيا تجي تقولهم تعال وتعاون معاي
فالتقنية مرة تطورت
أنا أشوف شخصيًّا لازم الآثار بشكل عام
تتعاون أكثر مع القطاع التكنولوجي
ما نكتفي إذا شخص فقط جانا وقال لنا
أنا هذا الجهاز اللي اشتغلت عليه كان في «جرش» بالأردن
في 2013 أو 2012 والله ناسية
كان يرسل إشاراتي، فهذا يختصر لك وقت
بس أهم شيء المناطق مثل الربع الخالي، الصحاري
التصوير عبر الأقمار الصناعية
هذه مرة مهمة واختصرت وقت مرة كبير
منها عرفوا، بالبادية عندنا على الشمال مع حدود الأردن
شافوا موقع للجيش الروماني
من تصوير جامعة «أكسفورد» بالأقمار الصناعية
بتختصر لك وقت مرة كثير
أنك على الأقل تحدد إذا فيه شيء ظاهر
هنا فيه سؤال، يقول هل الجن يحرسون الآثار؟
لا، هي طلعت الفكرة أكثر شيء في مصر
بالبداية من زمان لما بدأوا ينقبون عن الآثار
عثروا على غرفة مسكّرة، تحمسوا شافوا الذهب ودخلوا
فهو اللي صار، غرفة مسكّرة لها ممكن 5 آلاف سنة
فتخيل الميكروبات، البكتيريا، كلها اللي موجودة بالغرفة
فهم تنفسوها وبعد كم يوم ماتوا
فمنها طلعت لعنة الفراعنة أو ما أعرف أيش
بس هو ما في شيء كذا، لأن دائمًا إذا لقينا غرفة مسكّرة
دائمًا نفتحها لفترة كم يوم أو أسبوع حسب عمقها
تتهوى، يتغير الأكسجين، نلبس كمامة وندخل
حتى تلبس قفازات عشان مو تمسكها على طول
بس أن الأشياء هذه مرة...
ما قد قابلتِ جن؟
والله شوف أنا شخصيًّا ما قابلت جن
تفتحين وتضفين كنوز وذهب وتمشين
بالضبط، وحتى قصة الذهب فيه كثير ناس
دائمًا للأسف في كل العالم
كثير مواقع تتنبش ذهب
ترى الذهب مره قليل ينلقى
يعني أغلب اللي ينلقى ذهب حديث
فالناس رابطة الآثار كلها من الأفلام للأسف
أن اللي تروج لها
كنوز
هذا شيء غير صحيح، أغلب اللي تلقاها تماثيل
وأشياء دلالات جدًّا مهمة لنا
للأسف سبب التنبيش تروح علينا
فيه سؤال لطيف هنا، كيف تحددون عمر الموقع؟
فيه أشياء تكون، مثلًا الفخار يعطيك دلالات
الفخار اللي كل فترة يختلف
اللغة، حسب اللغة اللي مكتوبة
إذا هي بالفترات اللي بدأ
الإنسان بدأ يكتب من 3000 قبل الميلاد
مثلًا إذا شفت نقش اللغة «المسمارية»
بعرف أنها من بلاد «ما بين النهرين»
لغة رومانية بعرف أنها من فترة رومانية
فاللغة، نوع الفخار
مثل قلت لك، عصور ما قبل التاريخ
هنا يجينا الجيولوجيا نتعاون
وأحيانًا من القطع على طول تعرف
لأن يكون لكل فترة شكل معين من الأدوات الحجرية
فمنها تعرف حق أي فترة حجرية
ومثل ما قلت الفخار دليل جدًّا مهم
اللغة والنقوش اللي موجودة
كيف عرفوا معاني الحروف الثمودية؟
هذه فكوها، فيه دكتور على ما أعتقد في فرنسي
هو اللي درسها وفكها
وصارت كذا معرّفة مثل ترجمة موجودة؟
إيه، مثلًا أصعب لغة اللي فكوها هي «الهيروقليفية»
بسبب «حجر الرشيد» اللي انكتبت في ثلاث لغات
فمنها كانت «الهيروقليفية»
فلما قارنوا من لغة، للغة، للغة، الثلاثة بعدين قدروا يفكون الرمز
ما شاء الله، أنا شخصيًّا أشوف الناس اللي تقدر تفك لغة؛ هذول عباقرة
أنت تخيل تفك لغة محد أصلًا
يستخدمها حاليًّا
بس تعرف أيش الشيء الغريب؟
لاحظت في حائل، بس لا أحد يزعل، ممكن في مناطق أخرى
بس بحكم تجربتي، في حائل كنت أبغى أحد يفك لي نقش ثمودي
لأني صراحة ما أعرف، وما لي باللغة الثمودية، بس أني مهتمة فيها
كنت أسأل، فدلوني على واحد في حائل
فقلت له كيف تعرف؟ قال أبوي يعرف
قلت له إيه، بس أنت درستها؟ قال لا والله كذا نعرفها
بسبب كثرتها في حائل، بتحكي في «جبّة» بس
فيه 15 ألف نقش عندهم من مختلف العصور
شوف ترى حائل
كنز
مو كنز، شوف للأمانة السعودية كنز
لكن للأسف والله العظيم...
نجران، آبار «حِمى» لما تشوف الرسومات كأنك في متحف
بس نرجع، سبحان الله، يعرفها، قلت كيف؟
قال ترى كثير عندنا في حائل، أن الناس تعرف ثمودي
فشوف، سبحان الله، قال أنا عرفتها من أبوي
متناقلة من جيل لجيل
قال ما أدري كذا نعرفها، مو بأنه شيء أنا درستها
هنا فيه سؤال جميل على موضوع
كيف تقييمين تجربة الأردن ومصر في سياحة الآثار؟
ما هو في التنقيب وإنما في تحويلها إلى سياحة
أيش المفروض نتعلم منهم؟
وأيش المفروض نتعلم أننا ما نسويه مثل ما هم سووه؟
شوف، مصر من الرواد في سياحة الآثار
بس كمان ما نقدر نقارن
لأن مصر يمكن من 1700، ومن أيام «نابيلون» لما سرق آثارهم
الآثار في مصر، للأسف كثير من الرحالة أخذوا الآثار
بس مصر معروفة على مدار السنين
كانت الرحالة تجي فقط عشان تشوفها
لأنهم كتبوا عنها، وعندها المباني الضخمة مثل الأهرامات وغيرها
فمصر اشتغلت بسرعة على هذا الموضوع
التخصص موجود من زمان يدرّس بالجامعات
ما شاء الله، حتى لو تمسك أي طفل في مصر والأردن؛ يقولك التاريخ
أي واحد في الأردن تسأله يقولك
عن «جرش» أنها كانت مدينة رومانية، «الأنباط» أنها بـ«البتراء»
ما شاء الله، فيه وعي
احنا هنا اللي نحتاجه، أهم شيء تبدأ بالوعي
أنت تدرسها في المناهج، توعّي
أهمية أن أنت ما تنبش بالآثار
تسويق المواقع، فيه عندنا مواقع حتى ممكن
إذا ترممت بطريقة غلطة ما تدخل الـ«يونسكو»
إذا أنت استخدمت إسمنت، استخدمت أشياء معينة؛ ما تدخل
فأنت حتى على مستوى تشوف المواقع اللي قبل، هل ترممت صح؟
عشان نسوق لها
فيه كثير عندنا مواقع سياحية، بس مسكّرة ومسوّرة
ترى السياحة هي دورها أنت تعطيها الموقع جاهز
السياحة مو دورها تدرسها
هي السياحة عليها أنا أجيها أقول تفضلوا
هذا الموقع، هذه المعلومات؛ سوّقوا لها
بعدين أنت لازم تتعاون كمان مع البلدية اللي يسوون الطرق
تهيئة الطرق للمواقع، يكون فيه مركز زوار للمواقع
كثير ترى عندنا مواقع ما لها مركز زوار
بس «العُلا» لما تروح لها، كل موقع فيه مركز زوار
صحيح
عندنا هنا مافي
على مستوى المملكة كامل، فيه كثير أشياء نفتقدها
بس هناك مسوينها، بحكم خبرتهم بالمجال ولهم سنين طويلة
فيه سؤال عن موضوع الحضارة الإسلامية
دائمًا لما يتحدثون عن الآثار والتراث
هذا على حسب السائل، ما تركزون على الآثار الإسلامية
وأنتِ لك تغريدة في مايو 2012 أو 2011 على ما أظن
أن علاقتنا بالإسلام لا يجب أن تكون علاقة كدين فقط
وإنما كعمارة، كحضارة، كآثار
ليش مافي أي تركيز في حديثك وتغريداتك
عن موضوع الآثار الإسلامية؟
الآثار الإسلامية موجودة بكثرة في المملكة
حتى عندك على مستوى قصة «قيس وليلى»
ترى صارت في «نجد» في محافظة «الأفلاج»
وإلى اليوم اسمها مدينة «ليلى»
والغار لما تروح له الحين، اللي كانوا على أساس
يتقابلون في جبل «التوبات»
كلهم مبخبخ ووصخ ولا فيه حماية
عندك كمان مثلًا «درب زبيدة»
اللي كانت هي المواقع في فترات الحج الإسلامي
لكن المشكلة أقول لك مو في السعودية بشكل عام
المعلومات مو متوفرة بالشكل
وأنا أقول لك أنا من تجربتي
لكن هل فيه شيء معين؟
مثلًا تلقى في «أطلال» اللي كانت تسويها جامعة الملك سعود
وإلى الحين متاحة للجميع
بس هذه قديمة المجلة
فلما تجي تشوف الفترات، فيه عندنا فترات إسلامية
دخلت عندك الفترات الأموية والعباسية
وما ننسى كمان عندنا مكة والمدينة
وحتى الآثار اللي هناك
الطائف فيها كثير مواقع الإسلامية
فيه قصر يعود للفترة العباسية، إذا ماني غلطانة
الفترات الأموية موجودة
النقوش الإسلامية اللي عندنا مهولة
حتى قصائد حب وغيرها، وحتى بالطائف
وهذه معروفة، بس سؤالي ليش أنتم مو مهتمين فيها؟
مو أنا، أنا ما لي دخل
لا، أقصد أنتِ حتى في تغطياتك وحديثك ما تشيري لها
ماهي ماخذة حيّز من محتواك
لا، قد كتبت عن الفترة اللي قلت لك قريبة من الطائف
التي تعتبر الفترات الإسلامية المبكرة، المدينة اللي موجودة
لكن أنا من وجهة نظري، أن الفترات الإسلامية مره معروفة للناس
لأن، ما شاء الله، نشوف الشعب عندنا مره واعي
فلو تمسك أي أحد بالفترات الإسلامية بيقولك التاريخ كامل
بيقولك المواقع وكذا
أنا حبيت دام أني أقدر أحكي بهذا الزمن
الحمد لله، عندك مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
أن الناس توعى أن احنا أقدم
احنا مو مثل الفكرة اللي الناس قاعدة تروّج لها للأسف
مو محليًّا بس خارجيًّا، أننا فقط نتأثر
لا، احنا أثّرنا
وأثّرنا بحكم أن عندنا هذا التاريخ
حتى في فترة العصر الجاهلي، هو مو بجهل، هو جهل عن الدين
لكن مو معناته أن الناس كانت جاهلة
فأنا حبيت أوصّل أن فترة قبل الإسلام ترى لا تحسبون أن...
لأن الفكرة اللي كانت تروّج
أن احنا ناس ما عندنا حضارة، ما عندنا ثقافة
فهذا فيه العمق التاريخي للمملكة
قد أيش احنا نبعد
حتى ترى عندنا أحجار المسافة
موجودة أن باقي كم توصل للمكة، وهذه كم تصل للمدينة
فبالعكس، حتى الفترات الإسلامية عندنا كثيرة
كتب أو مراجع تنصحين فيها؟
شوف «أطلال» هي اللي ممكن تكون متاحة للجميع
على موقع هيئة التراث
فيها كثير حفريات بس قديمة اللي صارت
هي مجلة وللا كتاب؟
مجلة «أطلال»
إيه، مجلة «أطلال» كانت جامعة الملك سعود
ففيها كثير من الدراسات، بس قديمة المجلة
بس فيه كثير، عندك معهد «ماكس بلانك» الألماني، ينشر
الهيئة الملكية لـ«العُلا» تنشر
كمان أنا دائمًا أقول للناس إذا فيه موقع معين
فيه «قوقل سكولر» تحط اسم الموقع
وتطلع لك الأبحاث اللي صارت فيه
أنا في حالتي أحيانًا إذا ما لقيت
أحاول أتواصل مع نفس رئيس البعتة أو الجامعة
ويرسلون لي في غالب الأحيان، أو حتى لو دكاترة أسألهم
مثلًا هل عندكم خلفية من كذا
وعندنا الدكاترة اللي مختصين بالآثار، ماشاء الله، جدًّا مهمين
فهذولي كثير يفيدون، وأنا صراحة ما بخلوا علي ولا بمعلومة
قطاع الآثار والتراث، الآن بما أن فيه كليات كثيرة
هل هو من التخصصات اللي تنصحين فيها، وفيها فرص؟
وللا بتورطين الناس؟
شوف أنا أحبها للأمانة، ومثل قلت لك المملكة حجمها
البعثات اللي قاعدة تصير ما تغطي ولا 1%
العدد جدًّا قليل، حتى لو 100 بعثة لسه ما يعتبر عدد كبير
فالتخصص يحتاج ناس، يحتاج متخصصين
لكن عشان احنا نزيده، كما قلت لك، لازم على الأقل نقسّم
فلما أنا يكون عندي، بدل ما أجيب واحد من الجنوب للرياض
خلاص أنا عندي دائرة آثار مثلًا بالجنوب، فيها متخصصين
لأن الحين، ما شاء الله، عندك التخصصات
فيه: ترميم، إدارة متاحف، الآثار، حتى التراث يدخل فيها
فكثير تخصصات صارت توفرها الدولة، وزارات التعليم
فبالعكس. كمان ما في أي تخصص
إذا أنت ما اشتغلت على نفسك، لا تتوقع الفرصة تجيك
لو أنك في أحسن تخصص عليه طلب
فهنا يجي مجهودك الشخصي
أنت كمان لازم تشتغل على نفسك
مو تتخرج وتقعد، والله ما لقيت وظيفة!
سؤالي الأخير، وهو بقتبسه من سؤال أحد الأصدقاء
لأنه سؤال جميل ينفع يكون ختام
أيش المنطقة اللي ما بعد خذت حقها؟
كل المملكة
كل المملكة؟
والله العظيم كل المملكة
شوف أنا أحكي من مبدأ أن هذا شغفي
إذا أنت اكتفيت بالعلم لنفسك؛ أنت ما فدت أحد، ولا فدت نفسك
العلم فائدته أن أنت تشاركه
وأنا بالنهاية واجبي علي أخدم بلدي، وبالنهاية هو وطني
فالأشياء اللي موجودة
النقوش، والله العظيم، أنا أبغى الناس بس تاخذ لمحة
يروحون مثلًا جبل «عكمة» المكتبة المفتوحة، حائل، نجران
كل المناطق عندك من الجنوب، للشمال، للشرق
حتى في الشرقية فيه مواقع، ممالك قديمة، الموانئ القديمة
فيه مناطتحت البحر، لسه ما طلعت
فالمملكة بشكل عام، الربع الخالي
فوالله كثير ما أخذت حقها من ناحية...
بس لو افترضنا إذا بتكلم عن «العُلا» نموذج رهيب
لأنك تعطي الموضوع حقه، تتفقين معي؟ «العُلا» نموذج؟
إيه «العُلا» نموذج
المنطقة أخذت حقها خل نقول
فيه اليوم فرصة لموقع ثاني
يكون بنفس مستوى الاهتمام اللي صار في «العُلا»
أيش بيكون هذا الموقع؟
قلت لك لازم نسوي نظام مثل «العُلا»
اللي يتسمى دوائر في البلدان، فيها يكون مكتب
مفهوم، بس قولي لي موقع محدد
تقولين المنطقة هذه لو ما عندنا خيار إلا نهتم بمكان واحد
«الغاط»
«الغاط»؟ هذا انحياز واضح
لا، موقع فعلًا تشوفين فيه كل فرص النجاح
أن يتحول إلى وجهة سياحية عالمية
لو انحط فيه نفس الاهتمام اللي في «العُلا»؟
شوف ممكن أقولك موقعين، لأن الاثنين موقع بالـ «يونسكو»
اللي هو بئر «حِمى» في نجران، و«جبّة» بحائل
هذول نحطها في نقطة وحدة
لأن النقوش اللي فيها في حياتك
وأجزم لك عليها، ما راح تلقى زيها
أنا أبغى الناس بس تشوف الرسومات الصخرية
حق بئر «حِمى» اللي في نجران
بئر «حِمى» في نجران ووادي «جبّة» في حائل
إيه
وممكن نقول موقع ثاني، الجوف
لأن بحكم ما ذكرته، أقدم موقع للناس على مستوى قارة آسيا
عندك «نحت الجمل» وعندك «الرجاجيل»
وعندك حتى قلعة «ماردو»
مرة غنية
شوف اللي حلو بالسعودية
فيه ناس تسافر البلدان لبلد معينة، لمملكة قديمة
احنا ممالك
أنت لما تجي؛ تجربتك بالجنوب بتكون غير الشمال، غير الوسط
فكل منطقة بتروح لها
رحلة عبر الزمن، رحلة عبر التاريخ
تخيل أنت تجي مثلًا لـ«نجد» تروح لمملكة «كندة»
بعدين تطلع من مملكة «كندة»
تروح مثلًا للجوف وتشوف الممالك القديمة
تطلع وتروح لمملكة ثانية
فهذه كلها احنا نوفرها في بلد وحدة، وعلى نفس الفترة
ترى الممالك القديمة، الألف الأول قبل الميلاد؛ منتشرة
الطرق القديمة اللي كانت موجودة، ليش نشأت؟
لأن كان فيه ممالك، الناس تبغى توقف وتستريح
فالطريق بُني بناءً على المواقع الأثرية
للممالك القديمة اللي كانت موجودة
أنا ممتن لك حصة، شكرًا على قبول الدعوة، شرفتنا ونورتنا
شكرًا لك، إن شاء الله، تكون خفيفة لطيفة
ما قصرتِ، الله يحييك
شكرًا لك، يعطيك العافية
شكرًا لكم، شكرًا لفهدة القصيّر في إعداد وإنتاج هذا الحلقة
وفي التحرير أنس الخليل
فؤاد الهتلان في الإخراج الإبداعي
ياسر بن غانم في إدارة التصوير
في الإضاءة ياسر كدشة
في تسجيل الصوت عبدالعزيز المزّي وعبدالرزاق المزّي
والهندسة الصوتية محمد الحسن
وفي إدارة الإنتاج عبدالمجيد عمر
وفي الإشراف على الإنتاج رزان الدهيثم
وشكرًا للراعي الرسمي شركة «صفا»
هذا بودكاست سقراط
أحد منتجات شركة ثمانية للنشر والتوزيع